TO ASSEMBLY PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SO SECURITY COMMITTEE.
BEFORE WE BEGIN I HAVE A FEW
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO MAKE THIS
MORNIN.
FIRST MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TRAVIS ALLEN IS ABSENT TODAY AND
NO SUBSTITUTE HAS BEEN ASSIGNED
TO THE COMMITTEE.
SECOND WE HAVE SEVENTEEN ITEMS
ON THE AGENDA TODAY.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TO SP FOUR
FIFTY NINE PORTANTINO HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN SP ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE PAN.
AND FILE ITEM FOURTEEN S. B.
TWELVE SEVEN DIVIDE ACT OR ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND ALSO WILL TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SINCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
SO WITH THAT TO IN GO AHEAD.
WE GO AHEAD AND PRESENT --
SENATOR JACKSON.
YOU HOW PHONE NUMBER EIGHTEEN
SJR --
TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY [inaudible]
ALSO [inaudible]
OKAY FUND.
IT DOES MATTER WHICH I REALLY.
WE GO IN ORDER.
YES BOTTOM [inaudible]
FIFTEEN THIRTEEN TWELVE GOOD
MORNING.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF MY ON BEHALF OF MY THE
JOINT AUTHORS SENATORS JOSH
NEWMAN I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
S. B..
THIRTEEN TWELVE THIS IS A CLEAN
UP MEASURE THAT MODIFIES
DISABLED VETERAN SICKLY BENEFITS
FOR STATE WORKERS TO MATCH THOSE
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE. TO PUBLIC
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
BACK IN TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN I CARRIED TWO
BILLS THAT AUTHORIZED TO LIMITED
ALLOTMENT OF SPECIAL SICK LEAVE.
FOR DISABLED VETERANS WHO HAD
BEEN NEWLY HIRED INTO PUBLIC
SERVICE. ONE BILL PROVIDED THE
BENEFIT THE STATE WORKERS.
THE OTHER BILL PROVIDED IT TO
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES BOTH BILLS
PASSED THE LEGISLATURE
UNANIMOUSLY AND WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW.
THE GOAL OF THESE MEASURES WAS
TO PROVIDE A CUSHION OF SICKLY
FOR DISABLED VETERANS WHO ARE
TRANSITIONING FROM MILITARY
SERVICE.
BACK INTO OF CIVILIAN LIFE AND
SPECIFICALLY IN TO SCHOOL ARE OR
STATES SERVICE.
THE NEWLY HIRED EMPLOYEES WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE BENEFIT IF AT
THE TIME OF THEIR HIRING.
THEY WERE MILITARY VETERANS WITH
SERVICE CONNECTED HEALTH
CONDITIONS.
RATED BY THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
AS 30% OR MORE DISABLED.
THIS SICK LEAVE MAY BE USED ONLY
TO TREAT SERVICE CONNECTED
CONDITIONS AND IS SUBJECT TO
STRICT CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES. TO
ENSURE AGAINST MISUSE.
STATE WORKERS RECEIVE TWELVE
SICK LEAVE DAYS SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
RECEIVE TEN DAYS A FOR
CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES.
AND TWELVE DAYS FOR CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES BELIEVE MUST BE TAKEN
WITHIN ONE YEAR AFTER WHICH ANY
UNUSED LEAVE IS FORFEITED AGAIN
THE GOAL IS AS THEY TRANSITION
BACK AND THEY HAVE THE NEED FOR
SERVICES.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE OF PROHIBITED
OR DISCOURAGED FROM TAKING THAT
NECESSARY TREATMENT AYE AS THEY
TRANSITION BACK INTO A CIVILIAN
LIFE.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN SEATS US
SENATOR NEWMAN ASKED A FURTHER
QUESTION WHAT IF A STATE ARE
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE NOT A NEW HIRE
BUT IN EXISTING EMPLOYEE WAS
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL
GUARD OR RESERVES.
WHO WAS MOBILIZED ON TO ACTIVE
DUTY WAS INJURED OR BECAME ILL
DURING THAT DUTY AND THEN RETURN
TO CALIFORNIA TO THEIR STATE OR
SCHOOL JOB?
WITH A QUALIFYING SERVICE
CONNECTED CONDITION THAT NEEDED
TREATMENT.
CLEARLY THESE CATEGORIES OF
RETURNING DISABLED SERVICE
MEMBERS ARE TO BE AFFORDED
TRANSITIONAL SICK LEAVE AS WELL
SO THAT THEY CAN GET THE
TREATMENT FOR THEIR INJURIES
WITHOUT HAVING TO TAKE LEAVE.
WITHOUT PAY.
SO LAST YEAR SENATOR NEWMAN AND
I JOINTLY AUTHORED TWO
ADDITIONAL BILLS TO PROVIDE
COVERAGE FOR EXISTING EMPLOYEES
WHO ARE GUARD MEMBERS OR
RESERVISTS.
BUT THERE'S STILL WALKING GROUP
OF DISABLED VETERANS NOT COVERED.
CURRENT STATE OR SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE THAT NEITHER
NEW HIRES NOR GUARD MEMBERS BUT
HAVE NEVER THE LESS HAVE PRE
EXISTING SERVICE CONNECTED
CONDITIONS FROM EARLIER MILITARY
SERVICE.
IN THE ASSEMBLY LAST YEAR SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES VETERAN BILL WAS
AMENDED TO CLOSE A FINAL
COVERAGE GAP.
AND OFFER ADDITIONAL SICK LEAVE
TO SERVICE MEMBERS WITH PRIOR
EXISTING INJURIES BUT LAST
YEAR'S OTHER BILL.
PERTAINING TO DISABLED VETERANS
STATE EMPLOYEES DID NOT GET THAT
LOOPHOLE FIXING AMENDMENT AND
CONTINUE TO ADD COVERAGE.
ONLY FOR GUARD AND RESERVE
MEMBERS.
THIS YEAR'S BILL S. B. THIRTEEN
TWELVE WILL BRING DISABLED
VETERAN SICKLY FOR STATE
EMPLOYEES UP TO PARITY WITH THE
BENEFIT LEVEL THAT WE PROVIDE
CURRENTLY FOR SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
WITH THIS BILL ALL DISABLED
SERVICE EXCUSE ME ALL DISABLED
VETERANS IN STATE SERVICE WILL
BE COVERED EQUALLY AND FAIRLY TO
THE SAME BENEFITS STANDARD AND
THE SAME ACCOUNTABILITY.
WISHES WEREN'T SO COMPLICATED
BUT YOU KNOW WE DO THINGS
INCREMENTALLY.
AND THIS WAS THAT ONE OF THOSE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT BIT
THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO FIX SO --
IT'S AN IMPORTANT FIX FOR THOSE
WHO NEED THE SERVICES IT'S NOT A
LARGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE ARE BUT
IT IS A SUBSTANTIAL.
A POPULATION OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
A SERVE THEIR COUNTRY AND
DESERVE THE THESE PROTECTIONS
AND WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU TO ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS STILL OUR STORY AND
FLOORS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WE
SUPPORTED THIS BILL LAST YEAR
WHEN IT PROVIDED THE SAME SICKLY
BENEFIT TO ACTIVE DUTY.
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES THIS IS A
PARODY DEL AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT IT THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS TWENTY
MEMBERS.
I EXPLANATION JUST SAY YOU'RE.
YOU INTENDED UNIFORMITY ACROSS
OUR WORKFORCE YOU IDENTIFIED A
AREA WHERE YOU DIDN'T HAVE YOUR
COMPLETE IN THAT.
THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL A MOVE
THE BILL WE HAVE OUR QUORUM.
THANK YOU SENATE LIKE CLOSE.
OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER PUT IT
PERFECTLY AND INTO.
IF I WERE TO DO IT OVER AGAIN I
TRY THAT APPROACH AND THEN
SOMEONE MIGHT SAY WHAT THE HECK
IS THIS BILL ALL ABOUT.
BUT IT'S AN IMPORTANT BILL AND I
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH AS WELL I DO
HAVE US SUPPORT ON THIS AS SOON
AS WE GET A QUORUM WILL BRING UP
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU AND THEN I HAVE ONE OTHER.
YES NEXT ONE IS FILE ITEM
[inaudible] EIGHTEEN IF THEY
ARE.
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSUS IS A RESOLUTION
CALLING ON CONGRESS AND THE
PRESIDENT TO ADOPT A
COMPREHENSIVE ASSAULT WEAPONS
BAN AND ALSO CALLING ON CALPERS
TO DIVEST ITS GUN HOLDINGS.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT AFTER
THE LATEST SHOOTINGS WHERE WE
SAW THAT THE BOMB STOCK OF BEING
USED AND THERE WAS A CALL TO AT
LEAST BAND THAT'S IN THERE WAS A
PROMISE THAT WOULD HAPPEN.
NOTHING HAS HAPPENED ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING.
AND RAPID FIRE ASSAULT WEAPONS
WITH LARGE CLIPS OF AMMUNITION
HAVE ONLY ONE PURPOSE THE MASS
SLAUGHTER OF LARGE NUMBERS OF
HUMAN BEINGS.
THERE THESE OF WEAPONS ARE
DESIGNED FOR MILITARY USE TO
ACHIEVE THAT MISSION IN COMBAT.
FOR NEARLY EIGHTY YEARS EIGHTY
YEARS FEDERAL LAW HAS BANNED
MACHINE GUNS GRENADES AND BOMBS
OTHER WEAPONS OF WAR LIKE
ASSAULT WEAPONS.
THAT ARE SIMPLY TOO DANGEROUS TO
BE IN CIVILIAN HANDS.
CONGRESS PASSED AN ASSAULT
WEAPONS BAN THIS PART OF THE
VIOLENT CRIME CONTROL AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACT IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR BUT AS WE ALL KNOW.
IT EXPIRED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR AND WAS NOT RENEWED.
BEFORE ITS EXPIRATION.
THE FEDERAL ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF SCHOOL
SHOOTING VICTIMS BY FIFTY FOUR
POINT 4% ACCORDING TO A
QUINNIPIAC UNIVERSITY STUDY.
COMPARED WITH A TEN YEAR PERIOD
BEFORE THE BAND WAS IN PLACE THE
NUMBER OF MASS SHOOTINGS DURING
THE BAND FELL BY 37%.
AND THE NUMBER PEOPLE DYING FROM
MASS SHOOTINGS BY 43% BUT AFTER
THE BAN LAPSED IN TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR THE NUMBER SHOT UP
AGAIN.
AND IT'S TARNISHING ONE HUNDRED
AND 83% INCREASE IN GUN
MASSACRES AND TWO HUNDRED AND
39% INCREASE IN DEATHS.
THE ONLY GUN CONTROL MEASURE
THAT HAS TO HAVE A STATISTICALLY
SIGNIFICANT EFFECT ON THE NUMBER
AND SEVERITY OF SCHOOL SHOOTINGS
IS THE FEDERAL ASSAULT WEAPONS
BAN.
IT'S GOAL IS TO STEM HORRIFIC
MASS SHOOTING INCIDENTS IT WON'T
STOP EVERY GUN MASSACRE WE KNOW
THAT BUT IT WILL CUT DOWN ON
THEIR CARNAGE.
IT WILL ALSO REDUCE THE PROBLEMS
OF POROUS BORDERS FOR STATES
LIKE CALIFORNIA THAT A PASSED
TOUGH GUN CONTROL LAWS AND YET
WITH OTHER STATES BY HAVING
LACKS LAWS.
PEOPLE CAN SIMPLY TRANSPORT
THESE FIREARMS IN THE CALIFORNIA
THIS HAS TO BE TAKEN ON A
NATIONAL LEVEL AS WELL.
IN LIGHT OF THE STATISTICAL
SIGNIFICANCE I BELIEVE IT'S TIME
FOR CALIFORNIA'S INVESTMENT
POLICIES. TO MATCH THE VIEWS OF
THE STATE'S CITIZENS AND TO
STAND UP.
AND START SHOULD TAKE A STAND
WITH THE VICTIMS OF THESE
HORRIFIC CRIMES CAL STIRS HAS
ALREADY TAKEN THE STEP OF THE
VESTING ITS HOLDINGS INCOME
MANUFACTURE.
PERHAPS REALIZING THE DISCONNECT
RETIREES INVESTMENTS AND
TEACHERS MISSION OF KEEPING
STUDENTS SAY FROM THE CLASSROOM.
AND FURTHER AS PRESSURE IS
MOUNTING ON WALL STREET TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE.
I BELIEVE THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE
TIME FOR US AS A STATE THE CALL
UPON CALPERS INVESTMENT FIRMS
AND OTHERS WHO ARE ALSO RE
EXAMINING THEIR PORTFOLIOS MANY
OF WHICH ARE DROPPING GUN STOCKS.
AND ASKING WEAPONS MANUFACTURERS
WHAT THEY'RE DOING TO MAKE SURE
THEIR PRODUCTS DON'T END UP IN A
MASS SHOOTING.
SEVERAL MAJOR RETAILERS
INCLUDING DICK'S SPORTING GOODS
HAVE DECIDED TO STOP SELLING A
STALLED STYLE WEAPONS ALL
TOGETHER AND OTHERS LIKE WALMART
WILL BE RAISING THE AGE TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM IN THEIR
STORES. TO TWENTY ONE IN SHORT
THEY HAVE RECOGNIZED THAT GUNS
ARE BAD FOR BUSINESS AND CAL
STIRS I BELIEVE HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REINFORCE THEIR
POSITION.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE SOME RECURRENT.
MACHINERY EQUIPMENT COMMITTEE
CRAIG DELUDE UP AFTER THE FIRES
POLICY COALITION UP I YOU KNOW I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT KNOW THAT
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE IS
A RESOLUTION THAT SAYS.
A WE DON'T LIKE IT
CONSTITUTIONALLY ENUMERATED
RIGHT WHETHER WE LIKE IT OR NOT --
THE RIGHT TO KEEP AND BEAR ARMS
IS A NOTED IN OUR CONSTITUTION
THIS THERE FOR A REASON.
RIGHTS THAT OUR NUMERATOR THAT
OUR CONSTITUTION ARE BECAUSE
THEY'RE CONVENE.
THE RIGHT TO FREE SPEECH ISN'T
THERE TO BURST PROTECT SPEECH
THAT WITH WHICH WE ALL AGREE.
IN FACT IS THERE TO PROTECT
SPEECH WHICH SOME MAY FIND
OBJECTIONABLE.
AND I UNDERSTAND WE FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE SOME PEOPLE WELL
THEY CHOOSE NOT TO EXERCISE THE
RIGHT TO KEEP AND BEAR ARMS BUT
FOR THE STATE GOVERNMENT FOR THE
GOVERNMENT TO PUT FORTH A
RESOLUTION BASICALLY DECRYING.
THE RIGHT TO KEEP AND BEAR ARMS
AND LET US BE CLEAR THERE IS NO
SUCH THING AS AN ASSAULT.
WEAPON THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS
AN ASSAULT STYLE WEAPONS THERE
HAVE BEEN NO REAL SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES IN THE TYPE OF FIREARMS
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE A ARE
FIFTEEN WHICH IS.
KIND OF THE TARGET IN PARTICULAR
OF OF RESOLUTIONS LIKE THIS HAS
BEEN AROUND SINCE.
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT HERE IS NOT A GUN
PROBLEM IT'S NOT A TOOL PROBLEM
IT IS A PEOPLE PROBLEM IS THAT
IT IS AN ISSUE WITHIN OUR
SOCIETY THAT NEEDS TO BE TO
ADDRESS.
THIS NOT A GUN VIOLENCE THAT YOU
IT IS A VIOLENCE ISSUE ONE THAT
WE DO TO SERIOUSLY NEED TO TALK
ABOUT BUT AS LONG AS WE ARE
GOING TO AS A SOLUTION SEEK TO
DISARM.
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS AND USE THE
POWER OF GOVERNMENT --
TO PRESSURE BUSINESSES OF WHO
ARE ENGAGING IN THE FACILITATION
OF A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT I
THINK THAT WE ARE OVERSTEPPING
OUR BOUNDS AND IS THIS FOR IS
FOR THIS REASON.
THAT I ASK THAT YOU OPPOSE THIS
MAY THANK YOU.
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THE NAME MEMBERS.
MANY MEMBERS INCOME IT'S SENATOR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE TO A REF
REFERENCING THE FIRST AMENDMENT --
THE GENTLEMAN SUPPORTING THE
UNFETTERED RIGHT TO OWN FIREARMS
FORGETS THE FACT THAT THERE IS
NO CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT THAT IS
WITHOUT A LIMITATION.
AND UP UNTIL THE HELLER CASE WE
HAD TO A AFFIRMATIONS THAT A THE
SOCIETY AND A PUBLIC SAFETY TO
WARRANT.
A IN INSTANCES WHERE GUNS ARE
REGULATED.
THE WAY SPEECH WE DO NOT ALLOW
SOMEONE TO YELL FIRE IN A MOVIE
THEATER BECAUSE IT IS A THREAT
TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
FIRE ARMS AND SPECIFICALLY IN
THIS INSTANCE ASSAULT TYPE
WEAPONS ARE A THREAT TO PUBLIC
SAFETY.
THE STATISTICS DEMONSTRATE WE DO
HAVE A GUN VIOLENCE PROBLEM WE
HAVE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE KILLED
EVERY YEAR IN GUN VIOLENCE AND
THE FACT THAT WE ARE TALKING
HERE ABOUT LIMITING.
A THE WEAPONS OF WAR IS IN NO
WAY AN IMPAIRMENT OF ANYONE'S
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
AND IF YOU RECALL THAT THE
SECOND AMENDMENT STARTS WITH THE
PHRASE A WELL REGULATED MILITIA.
BEING NECESSARY TO THE SECURITY
OF A FREE STATE.
ARE IT IS APPALLING TO ME THAT
THE ARGUMENTS THAT WE HEAR
IGNORE.
CONTEXT OF THE SECOND AMENDMENT
AND ALSO IGNORE THE STATEMENT BY
ONE ANTONIN SCALIA IN THE HELLER
CASE WHICH AFFIRMED THE FACT
THAT OF THE RIGHT TO OWN
RIGHT.
THIS IS A REASONABLE MEASURE
THIS WILL HOPEFULLY SAVE LIVES --
THERE IS A RIGHT TO LIFE LIBERTY
AND THE PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS
THAT I BELIEVE I IS CHALLENGED
WHEN WE ALLOW WEAPONS OF WAR
LIKE THE WEAPONS THAT ARE ON THE
STREETS TODAY. TO GO A TO BE
AVAILABLE TO ANYONE AND EVERYONE
WHO SEEKS THEM WITH THAT I WOULD
URGE DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND AS YOU SEE
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM MINUTES
WE CAN BRING ARE FOR VOTE FOR
HAVE LONG COLLEGE YOU GET A
QUORUM THANK YOU [inaudible]
THIRD MEMBERS.
SO NEXT WE HAVE SENATOR LEYVA I
THOUGHT I CYNICAL ON IT.
SENATOR WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
PROTECTS THE RETRY RETIREMENT
BENEFITS OF CALPERS MEMBERS BY
MAKING SURE THAT ANY
COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED
COMPENSATION TOWARDS RETIREMENT
CANNOT BE FORCED TO BE PAID BACK.
TO INCORRECTLY REPORTED
INFORMATION BY THEIR EMPLOYERS
THIS MAJOR RESPONSE TO INTO
INSTANCES WHERE THE COMPENSATION
INFORMATION OF RETIRED EMPLOYEES
WAS MISCALCULATED FOR
INCORRECTLY REPORTED TO CALPERS.
BY THEIR EMPLOYERS IN THESE
INSTANCES THE RETIRED EMPLOYEES
ARE FORCED TO PAY BACK THE
OVERPAID AMOUNT AND EVEN SUFFER
REDUCTIONS IN FUTURE PAYMENTS.
THESE RETIRED EMPLOYEES MANY
TIMES IF NOT ALL THE TIME RELY
ON THEIR FIXED INCOME AND SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO TAKE UNEXPECTED CUTS
TO THEIR BENEFITS.
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR GIVES
RETIREES THE PEACE OF MIND THAT
THEY WILL NOT BE FORCED TO PAY
BACK MONEY OR HAVE REDUCTIONS IN
THEIR FUTURE PAYMENTS BECAUSE OF
THEIR PLAYERS ACCOUNTING ERROR
OR A REPORTING HERE.
WITH ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IS
CHRISTY BELMONT FROM THE
FIREFIGHTERS.
CHRISTIANITY THE MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTY VALMONT BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
PLEASED TO BE SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE.
BUT YOU KNOW WE HAD A MEMBER
START COMING TO US.
WELL ONE PARTICULAR STORY WOULD
SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE IN
TWENTY TWELVE A FIREFIGHTER WHO --
WAS A FIREFIGHTER FOR THE CITY
DAVIS FOR THIRTY YEARS.
AHEAD RETIRED FOR FIVE YEARS AND
THEN RECEIVED A LETTER IN THE
MAIL.
UP FROM THE RETIREMENT SYSTEM
SUGGESTING THAT.
THE EMPLOYER ALTHOUGH BARGAIN
FOR A BENEFIT.
PROMISED IT INTO RETIREMENT PAID
FOR IT.
SHE BOTH PAID FOR AS WELL AS HER
EMPLOYER THROUGHOUT HER CAREER.
THAT THEY NOW WOULD LIKE A
REMITTANCE OF A DIFFERENCE WHAT
THEY'VE DETERMINIST BEEN
DISALLOWED.
OF A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
MONEY AND PERMANENTLY REDUCED
THAT ALLOW IT'S GOING FORWARD IN
PERPETUITY WHILE THIS MEMBER.
GAVE HER LIFE TO THE FIRE
SERVICE AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC AND THEN HAS BEEN BECAUSE
OF AN ACTION OF THE EMPLOYER.
HOPE IS THE ONE LEFT HOLDING THE
BAG IN THE OBLIGATION.
BECAUSE OF THIS BILL
APPROPRIATELY CORRECTS THAT AND
PROTECTS A RETIREE DOES NOTHING
FOR ACTIVE EMPLOYEES OTHER THAN
TO SEND THEM BACK TO THE
BARGAINING TABLE BUT IF YOU'VE
ALREADY MADE THE ACTION TO
RETIRE.
THE BILL REQUIRES THE EMPLOYER
TO MAKE THE PAYMENT BACK TO THE
SYSTEM.
THE SYSTEM HOLE AND ALSO TO
ASSUME ANY UNFUNDED ACTUARIAL
LIABILITY THAT MAY RESULT FROM
CONTINUING THAT BENEFIT GOING
FORWARD.
SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
THINK ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MUCH.
SEEING NONE ANY COMMERCE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENIOR CENTER LIKE BECAUSE I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT YOU KNOW WORKERS
BOB MAKE DECISIONS BASED ON THE
PROMISES THAT THEY'RE MADE BY
THEIR EMPLOYERS THEY MAKE CAREER
DECISIONS TO GIVE ALL THE BEST
YEARS OF THEIR LIFE. TO AN
EMPLOYER WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE TAKE CARE OF THEM
IN RETIREMENT THEY DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY THAT THEIR BENEFIT THAT
THEY WERE PROMISED WILL BE CUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS SOON AS
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM WILL GO
AHEAD AND I DO HAVE I RECKON TO
GET TO THINKING.
SENATOR NELSON ELECT PRESENT.
SENATOR YOU HAVE S. B.
[inaudible]
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN AND TWELVE
SIXTY ONE YOU WANT TO START WITH
THE NUMBER. THIRTEEN TWELVE
SIXTY ONE THANK GOD [inaudible]
THIS.
LEGISLATION ALLOWS CALPERS TO
ESTABLISH A ONE FIFTEEN TRUST.
THAT WOULD ALLOW ANY ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIA AGENCY.
AND THAT.
WOULD TO PRE FUND FUTURE PENSION
CONTRIBUTIONS.
AND ANOTHER OPTION FOR THE
EMPLOYERS TO PAY DOWN THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY TO A DEFINED
BENEFIT.
PROGRAM.
THIS A PRIVATE SECTOR HAS HAD
AND THE COLD.
ONE FIFTEEN TRUST AVAILABLE THEY
WILL BE REVOKED WILL TRUST FOR
SOMETIME.
THIS WOULD ALLOW A SIMILAR
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALPERS
EMPLOYEES RETIRING BENEFIT
RETIREMENT BENEFIT TRUST.
AND IT'S LIMITED IN ITS ABILITY
TO PRE FUND.
OR OTHER POST EMPLOYMENT BENEFIT
LIABILITIES [inaudible]
BUT NOT [inaudible]
PENSIONS.
IT MARKET TRENDS AND CHANGES AND
FEDERAL ACCOUNTING AND FINANCIAL
COACH.
HAVE RESULTED IN DEMAND FOR THE
PUBLIC GOOD IT ENTITY
PARTICIPATION AND PROVIDED
OPPORTUNITIES [inaudible]
THAT ALLOW. FOR PUBLIC ENTITIES
SUCH AS THE ONE THAT'LL BE
TESTIFYING BEFORE US HERE TODAY.
A TO PRE FUND [inaudible]
AND THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THIS
THE CHANGING MARKET CONDITIONS.
AND THE NECESSARY OPPORTUNITY
THAT WOULD GIVE LATITUDE
[inaudible] TWO ORGANIZATIONS.
LIKE THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTED HERE BY
MR DYLAN GIBBONS.
WHAT?
PART OF SPORT.
HAD CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DON'T GIVE US WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION --
LIKE TO START BY THINKING CENTER
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL --
IS WELL IT'S THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND
CLIP MILES OF THE SENATE PURSE
COMMITTEE FOR FOR HIS WORK ON
THIS -- THIS
THIS IS A COLLABORATION BETWEEN --
CALPERS --
LABOR AND EMPLOYERS --
TO TRY TO COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION TO TRYING --
TO THE THE UPCOMING INCREASES
AND PUBLIC PENSION COSTS --
WHILE CURRENTLY THERE IS A ONE
FIFTEEN TRUST TO ESTABLISH THAT
ALLOWS PUBLIC AGENCIES TO PRE
FUND.
OTHER POST EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS --
YOU LED BY OVER FIVE HUNDRED
PUBLIC AGENCIES --
WITH SEVEN POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN ASSETS.
THERE IS NO SUCH TOOL TO PRE
FUND NORMAL BECAUSE OF PENSIONS --
WHERE WHERE OF THAT THAT THE
PENDING RATE INCREASES A CALPERS
RESULTING FROM A COMBINATION OF --
INVESTMENT LOSSES ACTUARIAL
ADJUSTMENTS AND AID REDUCED
AMORTIZATION PERIODS OF PUBLIC
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN SEEKING
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL TOOLS TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES IN THOSE AT
THOSE PINNING RATE INCREASES --
THE PRE FUNDING TRUST
ESTABLISHED IT A CALPERS THROUGH
S. B. --
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN WILL PROVIDE
AN AFFORDABLE OPTION FOR PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO PROACTIVELY MANAGE
THEIR PENSION OBLIGATIONS --
FUNDS INVESTED IN THE TRUST CAN
BE USED ONLY FOR PENSION BECAUSE
OF PENSION OBLIGATIONS.
THAT'S SUCH A INVESTED FUNDS CAN
BE USED TO OFFSET UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES REPORTED UNDER GOD'S
BE SIXTY EIGHT REQUIREMENTS AT
MAY IMPROVE --
AGENCIES BOND RATINGS.
ADDITIONALLY AGENCIES THAT
UTILIZE THE TRUST WILL BE ABLE
TO DRAW ON THE FUNDS AT IN THE
TRUST OFFSET THEIR ANNUAL
PENSION OBLIGATIONS --
SO IN YEARS WHERE THERE'S A RATE
INCREASE --
PARTICIPATING PUBLIC AGENCIES
WILL BE ABLE TO UTILIZE INVEST
FUNDS TO OFFSET THE INCREASE IN
COSTS IN SMOOTH OUT THEIR
PAYMENTS --
FURTHERMORE THERE'S A DOWNTURN
IN THE ECONOMY --
THERE'S A MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS HAPPENING WITH THE
PUBLIC AGENCY OR OTHER
UNFORESEEN FACTORS UP PUBLIC
AGENCIES CAN UTILIZE THE FUNDS
OF THE TRUST TO SUPPLANT THEIR
ANNUAL PENSION OBLIGATIONS.
OUT WHILE THERE ISN'T THE THIS
ISN'T THE BE ALL END ALL
SOLUTION TO ADDRESSING PENSION
OBLIGATIONS.
THOSE AGENCIES THAT CAN'T AFFORD
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS --
THIS WILL BE A BENEFIT IN AND IT
WILL BE ABLE TO ASSIST THEM IN A
PROACTIVELY DRESSER PENSION
OBLIGATIONS ARE AND FOR THESE
REASONS BEING --
AND COURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU BEFORE GOING FURTHER
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO GO AHEAD
AND SECRETARY CALDERON STUBS
FORM [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
ALAN [inaudible]
BRO THEIR THURMOND TENSE
[inaudible]
COOLEY HERE [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU SO THAT ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
COUNTIES PLEASES APART THINK ILL.
WELL MISTER BREAUX BEATEN TO THE
PUNCH I'D LIKE TO FREE FUNDING
TRUST IDEA WHEN I AUTHORED.
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY SIX TWO YEARS
AGO THIS IS A GREAT IDEA.
ALSO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT.
MY STATE SENATOR ARROGANT LIKE
GILSON.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH I FOR ONE FURTHER I
KNOW THERE WERE SOME A PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS JUST WONDER MIXTURE.
CENTER AND WILL BE OF NO USE AS
WELL.
SO I DO HAVE AN AYE RECCO IT'S
GOOD BILL AND SECRETARY LIKE
CALDERON.
ALRIGHT THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RODRIGUEZ AYE.
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN [inaudible]
BROUGH.
ROLL AYE CERVANTES.
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE COOPER
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I Q..
BEHOLD THE MEASURE UNCLE THAT
THE GOVERNMENT CENTER GO AHEAD
WITH THE NEXT.
TWELVE SIXTY ONE THE CHAIRMAN
RODRIGUEZ AND MEMBERS.
THIS CLARIFIES ORIGINAL INTENT
ALLOWS CAL FIRE TO CONTINUE
CONTRACTING [inaudible]
WOULD OUTSIDE CONTRACTORS TO
BRIGHT PILOTS [inaudible]
HELLFIRE [inaudible]
AIRCRAFT [inaudible]
SERVICES.
JANUARY OF EIGHTEEN HELLFIRE.
I DON'T KNOW CLARIFIED OR CAME
UP WITH THE NEW INTERPRETATION.
AN INFORMATIONAL LETTER THAT
THEY SENT OUT TO CONTRACTORS
THEY INDICATED THAT THE
CONTRACTORS WOULD HAVE TO BE
PROVIDING.
INSURANCE FOR THOSE PILOTS
[inaudible]
THEY PROVIDED [inaudible]
THE CALIFORNIA.
THIS CREATED A HUGE.
FOR PROBLEM AND CONCERN FOR THE
CALL WHEN NEEDED AND CONTRACTORS.
SENATE THAT THEY'VE LIKELY WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO DO THIS
[inaudible]
AND THEREFORE.
CAL FIRE PLANES WOULD BE IN
EFFECT GROUND ELECTED NOT HAVE
PILOTS.
WE'RE ALL VERY CLEAR OF THE
NEEDS.
FIRES AND THE CHANGING
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT HAVE
[inaudible]
EXACERBATED THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
FIRES WE HAVE TO SUFFER NOW.
SO THIS IS REALLY VERY IMPORTANT.
AND IT DOES WHAT WE WOULD ARGUE
CLARIFY THE ORIGINAL TEN INTENT
[inaudible]
THAT.
THAT LIMITS A BATH THAT THE
DEATH PENALTY THAT THE DEATH
PAYOUTS.
THE PILOTS WHO ARE FLYING THESE
AIRCRAFT.
BUT WHO ARE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS OR EMPLOYEES OF COMP
COMPANIES TO DO THIS.
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT THE SUPPLY
OF PILOTS TO KEEP THOSE PLANES.
COPIERS IN THE AIR IT WILL
HAPPEN.
AGAIN IT'S THE A PRODUCT OF THE
INTERPRETATION BY CAL FIRE WE
DON'T DISPUTE OR ARGUE WITH THAT
BUT WE DO NEED TO HAVE.
A REMEDY AND MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THIS WOULD PROVIDE THAT
REMEDY.
THANK YOU CENTER AYE ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
XENON ANY QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SYNERGY LA CLUBS.
ASKING AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO THERE'S MUCH SECOND
I DO SUPPORT THE BILL AS WELL
THINKER MUCH BRING THIS FORT
SECRETARY LICCARDO.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND RIVER
FOR TO APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ
FIVE HUNDRED IS AYE ALLEN.
BROKE.
BROUGH AYE CERVANTES COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I ALRIGHT WE'LL PLACE
AMONG CALM IS WHAT FURTHER ARMS
THANK YOU.
HAVE A GREAT DAY [inaudible]
DODD SENATOR DR COPEMAN PRESENT
ON S. B..
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR YES MISTER I
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
LAST YEAR I INTRODUCED S. B.
THREE THREE FOUR WHICH PASSED
THE LEGISLATURE UNANIMOUSLY AND
WAS SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR.
IT EXTENDED THE ENHANCE
INDUSTRIAL DISABILITY LEAVE E.
IDL. TO CAL FIRE FIREFIGHTERS.
I INJURED ON THE JOB DURING
TRAINING.
S. B. ELEVEN FORTY FOUR IS A
CLEANUP BILL TO THAT LEGISLATION.
THIS BILL THAT EXTENDS ANY
SALARY INCREASES GIVEN TO ACTIVE
FIREFIGHTERS TO THOSE ON E. IDL.
THIS EXTENSION OF SALARY
INCREASES TO THOSE ON EID AL IS
NOT AND PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAW.
IN FACT LOCAL FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL
POLICE THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL AND OTHER STATE AGENCIES --
ALREADY HAVE THIS.
AFTER THE DEVASTATING FIRES OF
MY DISTRICT LAST YEAR I'VE SEEN
FIRST HAND THE AMAZING HARD WORK
THESE FIREFIGHTERS DO.
I THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL IN AN IMPORTANT STEP TO
GIVE THEM SOME PARITY WITH OTHER --
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
FIREFIGHTERS S. B. ALUM FORTY
FOUR IT'S NO OPPOSITION IS
SPONSORED BY CAL FIRE LOCAL
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE WITH ME
HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT IS AARON READ.
THANK YOU GOTTEN ARM.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AT CAP
ARTICLE TWENTY TO ONE HIGH HE'S
EXPLAINED BILL VERY ADEQUATELY
THANK YOU.
I THINK ANYONE ELSE SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTY BELLAMY HALF
OF CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT.
QUESTION BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ECONOMIST CHAIR FINALLY A
SENATOR DODD BILL LIKE IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
UP UP [inaudible]
WIDELY.
SO IT THAT THERE IS A MOTION IN
THE SECOND I BELIEVE.
I AND I DO HAVE I RECOGNIZE GOOD
BILL --
SECRETARY LIKE TO CALL THE ROLL
OR I'M SORRY.
WE NEED A SECOND [inaudible]
HOUSE.
BUT ABSENT MOTION AND SECOND --
CENTERED LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU SECRETARY COLOR.
THE MOTION IF WE PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE.
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
GROWTH.
GROWTH PIES AVENTIS [inaudible]
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER [inaudible]
AND O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PLACE UNCLE LIKES.
NEXT WE HAVE SENATOR PARA.
SO POUND ONE START NAY OF A
COUPLE SO START WITH THE NUMBER
FOUR SB [inaudible]
SEVEN EIGHTY THREE ARE THEY IF
YOU GOOD MORNING [inaudible]
SO.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR HAVING HERE I
SP SEVEN EIGHTY THREE MAKES A
REQUEST BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA TO DEVELOP
A PENSION DIVESTMENT REVIEW
PROGRAM. TO ASSESS THE
INVESTMENT PROPOSAL SIMILAR IN A
MANNER. TO THE EXISTING PROCESS
UNDER DICK CALIFORNIA HEALTH
BENEFIT REVIEW PROGRAM SHOULD
BURKE.
EVENT WHICH LEADS THEY PROPOSALS
PROPOSALS TO MANDATE HEALTH
INSURANCE BENEFIT COVERAGE.
IT PROVIDES THE LEGISLATIVE HERS
COMMITTEE CHAIRS THE SENATE PRO
TEM AND ASSEMBLY SPEAKER.
NEWT FIRST BILL TO BE RID VIEWED
BY AT THE PD R. P. WHICH WILL
PROVIDE ITS ANALYSIS TO THE
CORPORATE POLICY FISCAL
COMMITTEES.
NOT LATER THAN SIXTY DAYS AFTER
RECEIVING REQUESTS THEY ALSO
REQUESTED UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATE WITH ACTUARIES
RECOMMEND BY THE CALIFORNIA
ACTUARIAL ADVISORY PANEL.
EXPERTS IN THE PUBLIC PENSION
FUND INVESTMENT MANAGEMENT
PROFESSIONS WELL AS USE
UNIVERSITY RESOURCES THAT%
SPECIALIZE IN PROVIDING
OBJECTIVE FINANCIAL POLICY
ANALYSES.
ALSO PROVIDES THAT TWO MILLION
APPROPRIATION TO PROVIDE INITIAL
FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM.
AND THE PURPOSE OF THIS PANEL IS
REALLY TO ESTABLISH A
DISPASSIONATE ANALYTICAL METHOD.
USING CLEAR CRITERIA TO ADD
VALUE EACH LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL
TO THE VAST TO RESTRICT PENSION
FUND INVESTMENTS. FOR THE
PROPOSAL'S.
BOTH IN TERMS OF COST ACHIEVING
PROPOSALS INTENDED POLICY
OBJECTIVE IN ORDER AT THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE
RECEIVED CURRENT ACCURATE DATA
INFORMATION WHEN CONSIDERING
PROPOSAL.
YEAH I WOULD MAKE NOTES THAT
CERTAINLY WE WANT TO BE SURE
THAT CALIFORNIA.
PROFESSORS AND ACTUALLY STANDS
BY ITS VALUES IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE DO SO IT'S ALSO WE ALSO
NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT OUR
RETIREMENT AND INVESTMENT SPURS.
HELPERS AND CAL STIRS OUR EXISTS
TO ENSURE THAT WE PROTECT DUE
RETIREMENT.
OF OUR STATE EMPLOYEES ARE
TEACHERS ARE OTHER --
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES AND I KNOW
THAT WE'RE ALWAYS TRYING TO
STRIKE THAT BALANCE AND IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE WELL
INFORMED IN MAKING ANY SORT OF
DECISION THAN LOOKING AT THE
RIGHT DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVES
THAT WE HAVE BEEN. TO ENSURE
THAT WE ADVANCE OUR ARE EVER
VALUE SO WITH THAT UMP RESPECT
WE ASK WHEN I VOTE AND HAVE
WITNESSES SUPPORT.
AGAIN CORBETT FIGURES TO
CALIFORNIA'S CALIFORNIA HEALTH
BENEFIT REVIEW PROGRAM WILL
DISCUSS HOW THIS PROGRAM WORKS --
IN TERMS OF SUCH A BIRD THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER SUPPORT.
GLENN BRING JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE IT WE
THINK THAT THAT'S A SUB POP WILL
APPROACH. TO TRY TO GRAPPLE WITH
THE MULTITUDE OF AREAS THAT NEED
TO BE DISCUSSED WHEN IT COMES TO
DIVESTMENT LEGISLATION WHAT
OFTEN HAPPENS IS THE LEGISLATURE
HAS VERY IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT SOME OF THE POLICY AND
MORAL ISSUES.
THAT ARE IMPORTANT AND NEED TO
BE DISCUSSED IN OUR CERTAINLY
WITHIN THE JURISDICTION IN
PURVIEW OF THE LEGISLATURE.
OF WHAT IS IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS
LEGISLATION IT'S HAS ALSO SET UP
A MECHANISM TO TRY TO BETTER
ASSESS THE LONG TERM FISCAL
IMPACT OF THE FUND WHICH HAS A
MAJOR IMPORTANT ON RETIREMENT
STABILITY FOR OUR MEMBERS.
WHICH IS EVEN MORE IMPORTANT FOR
EXAMPLE BECAUSE OF THE RECENT
PENSION REFORM ACT THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED BY THE LEGISLATURE A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO.
I NEW TEACHERS THAT YOU'VE BEEN
TRYING TO RECRUIT A RETAIN OVER
THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS ARE
GOING TO BEEP FACING A 1% --
INCREASE IN THEIR RETIREMENT
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CASTERS
BEGINNING ON JULY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR THIS KIND OF INFORMATION IS
NOT ALWAYS UNDERSTOOD AND IF YOU
WERE TO PASS A BASEMENT
LEGISLATION THAT CAN HAVE A
FISCAL IMPACT ON THE FUHRMAN.
DOCKING HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON A NEW TEACHERS SO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ALSO CONSIDER THE
POLICIES THAT YOU WANT TO
CONSIDER WHEN IT COMES TO
DIVESTMENT BUT ALSO THE
RETIREMENT POLICY ON HOW IT
MIGHT IMPACT THE RETIREMENT
SECURITY OF OUR CURRENT
EDUCATORS AS WELL AS OUR FEW
EDUCATORS FOR THOSE.
REASONS WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
YOU WANT SUPPORT DAVE WALRATH
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RETIRED
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
IN ADDITION TO THE COMMENTS MADE
ALREADY BY CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WIN SUPPORT THE BILL
WE SUPPORT THE THIRD PARTY
ANALYSIS PROCESS.
NOT BECAUSE WE DO NOT TRUST
CALPERS MCALISTER'S.
BUT BECAUSE FREQUENTLY THERE ARE
QUESTIONS ASKED.
ABOUT WHETHER THEY HAD A A SOME
ON THE SCALE.
A WE DON'T BELIEVE THEY DO BUT
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT IT IS A
NEUTRAL THIRD PARTY ANALYSIS.
THAT ALL PEOPLE CAN WORK WITH WE
SUPPORT THE TEMPLATE --
PROCESS IN LOOKING AT FIRST
ENGAGEMENT.
CARTER GOING INTO A
DIVERTISSEMENT PROCESS IT IS
HARD TO CHANGE A FIRM'S BEHAVIOR
IF YOU'RE NOT AT THE TABLE AND
WHEN YOU'RE DIVESTITURE NO
LONGER AT THE TABLE.
WE BELIEVE ENGAGEMENT SHOULD
ALWAYS BE TRIED FIRST WE BELIEVE
IT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL AND
NUMBER OF CASES.
OUGHT AND FOR THAT REASON WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL STRIKES A VERY
GOOD BALANCE BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE'S OBLIGATIONS AND
RIGHTS.
I AS FAR AS SAY POLICY IN
ASSURING THAT THE OBLIGATIONS OF
PENSION SYSTEMS ARE MATT AND THE
PROVISION OF SERVICES AND
BENEFITS.
TO MEMBERS AND RETIREES ARE MET
FOR THOSE REASONS WERE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE SPORT.
GOOD MORNING DEREK CLINICS ON
BEHALF OF THE SCHOOL PLAYER'S
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION CLAPPING SUPPORT.
GOOD MONEY VINE GOT REAL WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING TERM MEMBERS START
THE JOHNS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
PLEASES SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TED TOP AND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE RETIREES
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE BEEN --
STRONG ADVOCATES FOR ENGAGEMENT
AND NOT DIVESTMENT WE THINK THIS
IS A GOOD [inaudible]
WHICH NEITHER.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANYONE OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE SOMEBODY COME.
YES MY NECK MY NAME IS.
IT DIDN'T PLAN IS PRISTINE
SHOEMAKER I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
PALM THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
LEGISLATIVE ACTION TEAM.
AND WE DID SUBMIT A LETTER IN
OPPOSITION I THINK IT WAS A
LITTLE BIT LATE BUT I THINK IT'S
ON YOUR LIST OF OF LATE LETTERS
THANK YOU.
ANY COMES COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BUT YES I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IS ONE TO THINK THE OFFER FOR
THIS EFFORT RELEASE APPROACH.
I THINK IT'S A WISER APPROACH A
MUCH MORE THOROUGH APPROACH AND
WE GET A BUNCH OF DIVESTMENT
BILLS EVERY YEAR EVERY YEAR
RIGHT AND REALLY I THINK WHAT IT
OUGHT TO BE.
GOING FOR MISTER CHARGED THAT
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE COMMITTEE
MAYBE NEXT YEAR IS THAT.
WHEN SOMEONE DOES WALK UP WITH A
DIVESTMENT BILL I THINK THEY
NEED TO IDENTIFY --
WHERE THEY CAN GET THE DOLLARS
TO OFFSET THE LOSSES FOR THEIR
PROPOSAL --
BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW THAT WE HAVE
A SIGNIFICANT PENSION --
PROBLEM IN THIS STATE AND
OBLIGATIONS.
TO AND THIS IS MEMBERS MONEY IT
DOESN'T MONEY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN JUST TAKE AND DO
WHAT THEY WANT.
OR NOT WANT WITH --
BUT THAT WE REALLY NEED TO HAVE
A THOUGHTFUL APPROACH I THINK
THIS IS A MORE THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUICK.
SOME ARE BROKEN THING WAS CHAIR --
NOT A BIG FAN OF THE INVESTMENT
I THINK IT'S DEFICIENT
RESPONSIBILITIES FUNDS GET THE
MAXIMUM PROFIT FOR THEIR MEMBERS
HOWEVER --
IN CALIFORNIA DIVESTITURE IS A
REALITY SAW BE SPORTING A BILL
TODAY. ONE QUESTION --
IS IS JUST LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS
ARE SAFE CALLOUSED OURS BOARD
DECIDES TO DIVEST IN A CERTAIN
INDUSTRY A PRODUCT DOES THAT GO
THROUGH THIS COMMISSION
PROCESSORS AT JUST THE
LEGISLATURE.
SO THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY FOR
LEGISLATION SO BECAUSE BUT
CERTAINLY IT WITHIN THAT OF RACE
PENSION FUNDS --
THEY IN MAKING THOSE DECISIONS
ARE AND THEY CAN SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES BUT I AM AWARE THAT
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT SILLY THEIR
INVESTMENT PERSON NOW.
ARE.
I'D GO OVER AND PRESENT TO THEM
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT POTENTIAL
CONSEQUENCES ARE THEY DO HAVE A
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY.
ARE UNDER LAW --
AND I THINK EVEN UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION TO TO TO BE SURE WE
GET THAT I RETURN THE CHALLENGES
IS THAT WHAT I'M SOME WE AS THE
LEGISLATURE GIVE DIRECTION --
WHAT THIS BILL AND PROCESS DOES
IS THAT IT HELPS INFORM THAT SO
THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS BILL
THAT YOU KNOW SOME PEOPLE MAY
PREFER BROWN THAT THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS BILL SAYS WE
CAN'T PASSIVE INVESTMENT BILL?
BUT I THINK WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT
THIS BILL THAT ENSURES THAT
THERE IS A MORE THERE ARE
THERE'S A THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF
WHAT THE IMPACT THIS WILL HAVE
ON THE RETIREMENT FUNDS BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY THE PURPOSE OF
RETIREMENT FUNDS IS TO ASSURE.
THAT WE PROVIDE THAT ARE ABLE TO
MEET OUR PENSION PROMISES TO OUR
SIMPLY EASE AND OUR TEACHERS.
THANKS VERY MUCH TRANSCEND
CENTER.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SEEING NONE SENATOR
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I THINK
YOU.
THEIR MOTION IN THE SECOND.
MOTION SECOND SENATOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGS FORTIS IS
LONG OVERDUE SOMETHING WE SHOULD
HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT SOONER.
AS WE TALK ABOUT SOME.
ISSUE THE COME WITH DIVESTMENT
SEN WE GOTTA DO WHAT IT DOES TO
THE FUNDS RIGHT.
THAT WE HAVE A DUTY TO PROTECT
OUR RETIREES NOT ONLY THE
CURRENT ONES BUT OUR FUTURE
RETIREES WELL ENOUGH A RESTORED
TO CHIP AWAY AT THOSE FUNDS
LITTLE BY LITTLE.
THERE'S NOTHING FOR THEM AND THE
DAY SO IT'S A GOOD BILL ARE LIKE
WE'RE GOING TO DO IN.
HAVE THAT THIRD PARTY LOOK AT
ANY GIVE US A AN OPINION AND HOW
THAT WOULD WORK IF WE WERE TO
ENGAGE IN THAT.
TYPE OF DIVESTMENT SO WITHOUT
GOV I RECKON AND EVERYONE WAS
JUST A GUY TO JUST ONE THANK YOU
AND YOUR COMMITTEE FOR A JOINING
WITH THAT THE SENATE COMMITTEE
AS WELL AND DOING A JOINT
HEARING I WANT RECOGNIZE.
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
PARTICIPATION AND THE HELP LEAD
TO THIS BILL SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH --
CENTERED LIKE COLOR.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE.
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
GROWTH.
BROUGH AYE CERVANTES
[inaudible]
COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER AYE O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I WE'RE GOING TO BROWN
CALL AND I KNOW YOU HAVE ANOTHER
ONE CENTER SP TEN TWENTY TWO YES.
RIGHT THANK YOU AGAIN THIS SHARE
MEMBERS --
SP TEN TWENTY TO MAKE CHANGES TO
THE PROCESS BY WHICH CONTRACTING
AGENCIES CAN TERMINATE THE
CONTRACT A WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
SYSTEM.
THIS BILL PERMITS CONTRACTING
AGENCIES TO MORE RAPIDLY
TERMINATE THE CONTRACT TO PAY
ASSOCIATED TERMINATION FEES IN
ORDER LIMIT ON GOING PENSION
LIABILITY.
REQUIRES TERMINATING AGENCIES TO
NOTIFY PAST AND PRESENT PLOY
EASE AND RETIREES AND WRITING OF
THE INTENT TO TERMINATE THE
CONTRACT WITHIN SPECIFIED TIME
LINES.
REQUIRES CALPERS TO SHARE MEMBER
AND AND NEW IN IT DATA WITH THE
CONTRACTING AGENCIES OF THE
AGENCIES.
I FELT THEIR OBLIGATION TO
NOTIFY THEIR PAST AND PRESENT
EMPLOYEES AND RETIREES.
IT'S GOT THAT LIKE WHICH FROM
CALPERS THE ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
EXPECT WE ASK FOR AYE VOTES
[inaudible]
THE GRANT.
OF SCOTT BLACKLEDGE FROM CALPERS --
OUR BOARD SPONSORED THIS BILL TO
A ALLOWABLE INTERIOR TERMINATING
AGENCIES TO MORE RAPIDLY --
IT EXECUTE THEIR CONTRACT
TERMINATIONS IN ORDER TO SAVE
MONEY.
A WHILE AT THE SAME TIME ALLOW
THEIR EMPLOYEES THAT ARE
AFFECTED BY THE CHANGE TO ENGAGE
WITH THE EMPLOYER --
THESE TIMELINES HAVEN'T CHANGED
OVER SEVERAL DECADES AND WITH
RECENT PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS WE
FEEL COMFORTABLE IN ALLOWING
THIS TO OCCUR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SIR ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY COMMENTS COMMITMENT HERS.
SENATOR JIM LIKED CLOSE.
ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE BUT
THANK YOU.
AND WITHOUT I ALSO SUPPORT THIS
BILL IS WHAT'S GOOD BROKEN
FOURTEEN WITH THAT DO HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND.
SECRETARY RIDGE LIKE CALDERON.
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN [inaudible]
WELL.
ROLL EYES AVENTIS [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER.
COOPER I O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I OKAY WON'T HOLD THAT
MEASURE ON BECAUSE WELL AND YOU
HAVE YOUR LAST ONE PHONE NUMBER
ELEVEN AT ELEVEN SIXTY SIX GO
AHEAD AND READ.
OUR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CAN SB ELEVEN SIXTY SIX
REQUIRED TO CALPERS CONTRACTING
AGENCY NOTIFY ITS MEMBER OR
RETIRED MEMBER WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS OF THE AGENCY FAILS TO MAKE
EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTIONS TO
CALPERS WITHIN THE APPLICABLES
TIME.
THE BILL REQUIRES CALPERS
PROVIDE THE AGENCY OF CONTACT
INFORMATION DATA SPECIFIED SO
THE AGENCY CAN PROVIDE THAT
REQUIRED NOTICE.
THE NOTIFICATION PROVISION OF
THE CONTRACT CONTACT DATA IS
ONLY REQUIRED IF THE AGENCY
FAILED SECURE IT'S DELINQUENCY
WITHIN SEVEN DAYS.
THE BILL ALLOWS RICK ACTIVE
RETIRED CALPERS MEMBERS TO KNOW
MORE QUICKLY WONDER CONTRACTING
AGENCY MAYBE HAVING FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTIES THAT COULD AFFECT
THEM THE MEMBERS PENSIONS.
I UNDERSTAND STAKEHOLDERS
CONCERNS REGARDING BURNS ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND AGENCIES
CONTINUE TO WORK TO ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS HOWEVER OF OF IT
THAT I KEEP THIS BILL MOVING I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT RETIREES
AND OUR EMPLOYEES.
KNOW THAT IF THERE MIGHT BE
POTENTIAL THREATS TO THAT TO THE
PROMISES THAT THEY WERE MADE
REGARDING THEIR PENSIONS.
ONGOING BASIS EXPECT WE ASK WHAT
I'VE IT.
PLUS BUT RICHARD BELIEVE HILLARY
COMMITTEE THOUGHT TAKING OVER
TEMPORARILY --
BECAUSE THE COMMITTEE.
EMBRACE AND SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
A TED TOPPING FOR THE STATE
RETIREES IN FOR THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA STATE SUPERVISORS
AND SUPPORT [inaudible]
VIRGIN EITHER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AARON READ
REPRESENTING PARKINSON PORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. TO CHECK MEMBERS PET
RAN EVERYTHING THE RETIRED
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MORNING RYAN CHAIRMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
SPORT THANK YOU.
ANYBODY OPPOSITION WITNESS
BECAUSE ITEM.
LOCAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
IS THERE A MOTION.
A SECOND THAT [inaudible]
LOCAL POLICE.
BUT ONE OF OUR CIVIL YES FOR NOW
BUT THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BRUNO [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER I COOPER I O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I IT THAT KILLED UNCLE
OKAY BUT YOU THANK YOU EXTRACT
.
OKAY WE'VE GOT A MOTION WITH THE
CONSENT COUNTERS ARE SECOND
[inaudible]
ALSO GONNA [inaudible]
ROLL CALL.
YES SIR CONSENT CALENDAR IT WILL
COLLECT THE CALIBER PLEASE PAY
THE CONSENT CALENDAR I'M.
GOING. ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE AND SB
TWELVE SEVENTY RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
BRILL.
WELL I CERVANTES [inaudible]
COOLEY.
COOPER AYE COOPER AYE O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I MORNINGS EARLIER
THAT MORNING NEXT UP IS SB.
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES THAT
TODAY I AM PRESENTING S. B.
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE WHICH WOULD
ALLOW.
THAT PEACE OFFICERS RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA PORAC
TALK FOR ITS MEMBERS REGIONAL
RATES FOR THE HEALTH BENEFITS.
I CURRENTLY PORAC OFFERS HEALTH
BENEFITS TO THEIR MEMBERS
THROUGH A HEALTH BENEFITS TRUST
ADMINISTERED BY CALPERS --
THIS HEALTH BENEFIT TRUST IS
OVERSEEN INTERNALLY.
AT POOR ACT BY THEIR INSURANCE
AND BENEFITS COMMITTING.
PORAC --
COMMITTEE CURRENTLY OFFERS FOR
ACT MEMBERS HEALTH BENEFITS AT
STATEWIDE RATES ACCORDING TO
CALPERS. FOR I CANNOT OFFER
ALTERNATIVE RATES WITHOUT
AMENDING GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION.
TWENTY TWO EIGHT FIVE OH WHICH
IS THE SECTION A LOT WHICH
ALLOWS CALPERS HEALTH BENEFITS
TRUST TO OFFER THEIR MEMBERS
REGIONAL RATES AGAIN THIS CHANGE
ONLY AFFECT CORAX TRUST.
AND PARKS OWN MEMBERS AND ONLY
IF THEY CHOOSE IN THE FUTURE TO
OFFER THE RETURN RATES AND TODAY
I HAVE EVER READ REPRESENTING
CORRECT TO SPEAK ON BEHALF.
OF THE BILL.
THAT YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND READ REPRESENT POOR
ACT A THIS IS THEIR OWN HEALTH
BENEFIT TRUST IT'S VOLUNTARY
WHETHER THEY CHOOSE TO MOVE IN
THAT DIRECTION BUT I WOULD POINT
OUT THAT THE PURSE PLANS DO
REGIONAL RATING.
SO THE PLANS OFFERED BY PURRS
ITSELF ALLOWS THAT BUT BECAUSE
THIS IS A HEALTH BENEFIT TRUST
JUST FOR POOR ACT THEY HAVE THE
SEEK THIS CHANGE IN THE LAW
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY.
GOT A MOTION THEIR SECOND.
THOSE MOTIONS BECAUSE POOR THE
BILL.
WELL WE CAN WHICH IS BECAUSE
OPPOSITION.
CALCLOUD PUBLIC COMMENT BUT MOST
OF THE FLOOR REPUBLICS ARE
ACTUALLY SENATOR SPECTER HAVE
OVER RIVAL THANK YOU.
OKAY THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
BRILL.
GROW AYE CERVANTES COOLEY.
COOPER AYE COOPER AYE O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THANK YOU BILLS
UNCLE WITH HER MAKING
.
SO I JUST WITH US ON THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AND WE GOT ONE ON THE WAY
.
WHICH WAS WE HAD.
I'M SITTING HERE HEARING ON WE
ARE GONNA.
SO MY QUESTION PEOPLE
[inaudible]
THURMOND [inaudible]
NUMBER
[inaudible]
THE FACT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
I THINK.
WELL.
REALLY ASKING THAT WILL BE
[inaudible]
IT WAS [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
I AND THERE ME.
YEAH XIN LING GET [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
UNDER TAB
.
RIGHT COULD YOU GUYS
[inaudible]
WITH THEIR MY HOPE
.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR.
THAT MORNING AT CHAIR COOPER
ANDREAS.
NEXT UP IS I'M FEELIN NEXT UP IS
S. B..
NINE SIXTY FOUR WELL MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH --
WE'RE OFFERING CIGARETTES TODAY --
I KNOW YOU HAVE SENATOR THURMAN
IS PRETTY PRESENT YOUR LITTLE
LATER HE'S LITTLE PRESENT RIGHT
NOW TO BILLS OR IN [inaudible]
EDUCATION.
SO THIS BILL.
DEALS WITH MATERIAL FINANCIAL
RISKS ASSOCIATED CLIMATE CHANGE.
THAT --
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED BY CALPERS.
AND CAL STIRS WHEN MANAGING
THEIR FUNDS.
NOW BOTH OF THE THE FUNDS HAVE
BOTH OF THE THE PLANS HAVE
GOVERNS DIRECTIVES THAT ADVISE
THEM TO TAKE CLIMB RISK INTO
ACCOUNT WHEN THEY'RE MAKING
THEIR INVESTMENT DECISIONS.
OUR CLIMATE CHANGE POSES FOUR
DIFFERENT TYPES OF RISK TO THE
VALUE OF FUND ASSETS THAT SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED.
BY FUN FIDUCIARY THIS INCLUDE
PHYSICAL RISK.
TRANSITION RISK STRANDED ASSET
RISK.
LITIGATION RISK SO FOR EXAMPLE
IF YOU KNOW.
IF I IF YOU THINK ABOUT BUYING
WHAT A REAL ESTATE ON THE COAST
IN BANGLADESH.
YOU ARE TO CONSIDER THE FACT
IT'S HERE'S A A PHYSICAL
CHALLENGE A OF A THREAT AND
VULNERABILITY.
ASSOCIATE WITH THOSE ASSETS IF
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT INVESTING
IN A COMPANY THAT --
COULD.
BE HEAVILY REGULATED --
UNDER THE U. STANDARDS THAT HAVE
BEEN ADOPTED IN THE WAKE OF THE
PARIS ACCORDS OUT TO BE
SOMETHING THAT.
YOU ARE TAKING ACCOUNT MAKING
INVESTMENT DECISIONS.
NOW GLOBALLY THESE RISKS AND HOW
TO ACCOUNT FOR THEM OF BEING
TAKEN VERY SERIOUSLY.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN FRANCE BECAME
THE FIRST COUNTRY TO REQUIRE
MANDATORY CLIMATE CHANGE RELATED
REPORTING. FOR INSTITUTIONAL
INVESTORS THE EUROPEAN
PARLIAMENT THEN PROCEEDED.
THE NEXT YEAR AND IN APPROVING A
DIRECTIVE REQUIRING PENSION
FUNDS TO ASSESS CLIMB A RISK
ALONG WITH OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
SOCIAL.
AND GOVERNANCE RISKS IN THEIR
INVESTMENT DECISIONS AND TO
INFORM FUND MEMBERS AND FIT AND
BENEFIT BENEFICIARIES OF THEIR
FINDINGS.
CALIFORNIA'S LEAD THE WAY ON SO
MANY THINGS RELATING TO CLIMATE
CHANGE.
OUR PENSION FUNDS ARE ALREADY
LEADING THE WAY AND ENSURING
THAT BICYCLING RISK IS BEING
TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
WITHIN THE GLOBAL COMMUNITY WILL
GET THE STRESS AS THEY OUGHT TO
TAKE.
INTO ACCOUNT THE REALITY OF
CLIMATE.
WHEN THEY'RE MAKING THEIR
DECISIONS IT DOESN'T TIE THEIR
HANDS DECISIONS AT THE END OF
MAKING?
AND YOU KNOW THIS BILL CODIFIES
THAT COULD WORK IN.
HOW WE RESPECT THAT'S WHEN I
VOTE?
THANK YOU HOPES.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS DAN JACOBSON
WITH ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
SORRY FOR BEING LATE --
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
UNEARNED.
HAPPY TO CO SPONSOR THE BILL.
BECAUSE OF EXACTLY WHAT THE
SENATOR WAS SAYING WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT WHAT THE RISKS ARE GONNA
BE.
IN ORDER TO MAKE THE SMARTEST
INVESTMENTS POSSIBLE.
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL DOES.
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE NOT VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE CAL STEWART HAS BEEN
ONE OF THE INTERNATIONAL LEADERS
WHEN IT COMES TO ENVIRONMENTAL
INVESTING FOR MORE THAN A DECADE
IT'S BEEN CONSISTENT WITH THEIR
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY.
WE APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THE
AUTHORS RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANT
ROLE THAT CASTERS HAS PLAYED AS
A LEADER ON THIS ISSUE.
AND WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
MEASURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JANET* OF POSSIBLY
CALIFORNIA WHERE ALSO A SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
MEASURE.
LINDA ESCALANTE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
BANKS.
SO MY NAME'S CHRISTINE SHOEMAKER
THREE FIFTY BE AREA IN STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
EMINEM'S MORGAN THE MONO ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS I'M WITH SUPPORT
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS ASIAN
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK.
FRIENDS OF THE EARTH SEIU
CALIFORNIA GREEN CENTURY
INVESTMENTS AND GLENDALE
ENVIRONMENTAL COALITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS ITEM.
OKAY ME COMES FROM THE COMMITTEE.
A IT'S GOT A FEW COMMENTS ON
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS RETIRED
MEMBERS ALREADY FACING
CHALLENGES ME IN THEIR DAILY
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS.
AS OF LAST REPORT CAL STIRS
DROPPED TO SIXTY TWO POINT 6%
SOLID THEORY AND CALPERS REMAINS
A SIMILAR PERCENT SALAS THE RATE.
EVEN AFTER INFUSION OF SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET TOM ADDRESSING CONCERNS
FROM WITH LEGISLATION THAT
DIVEST.
OR OPEN THE DOOR INVESTMENT.
ON THE BACK OF KERN RETIRED
EMPLOYEES IN THE SYSTEM THIS
DIFFICULT I LOOK AROUND THE
BUILDING I SEE OUR EMPLOYEES IN
THIS THIS HAS POTENTIAL TO
AFFECT.
OTHER RETIREMENT I'M IN MY
DISTRICT --
I HAVE THE LARGEST NUMBER OF
CURRENT EMPLOYEES AN ACTIVE
EMPLOYEES I THINK.
THE LARGEST IN THE THINGS I DO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THAT.
IN THE COULD DIVESTMENT FROM --
CASTERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CALPERS CALPERS IF AUSTIN
BILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE THE
DIVESTMENT SO.
EVERY YEAR WE WILL INVESTMENT
BUILT AND OPENED THE DOOR UP.
AND I WALK AROUND THE COULD
THESE FOLKS IN THE BUILDING WHO
I WORK WITH AND SOME IN THE
AUDIENCE THAT I DO HAVE
RETIREMENT I THINK FOLKS THAT
WOULD HAVE RETIRED ALREADY --
THEY WERE GIVEN THAT CONTRACT
AND THEY HAVE A CERTAIN RIGHT
[inaudible]
SO.
IT'S TOUGH BECAUSE THERE ARE A
LOT OF DIVEST MINTS BE IT.
AB A MYRIAD OF THINGS AND I KNOW
THIS IS OPEN THE DOOR.
I DON'T KNOW DOES NOT EFFECTIVE
BUT IT IT'S STILL OPEN THAT DOOR.
AND THAT THAT'S THAT'S MY
CONCERN SENATOR.
MISTER CHAIR I I RESPECT AYE AYE
BY I SHARE YOUR CONCERN ABOUT
RICIN BILLS THAT FOR THE VERY
REASONS YOU [inaudible]
ARTICULATED --
BUT I I CAN'T EMPHASIZE ENOUGH
OF THIS IS NOT A DIVEST IMPELLED
THIS JUST.
ALL IT DOES IS ASK THEM TO TAKE
IN ACCOUNT THESE RISKS.
AND THE IDEA THE IDEA BEING THAT
IT ACTUALLY.
ARE THAT WHICH YOU KNOW IT
WITHOUT THINKING ABOUT THESE
RISK THEY'RE ACTUALLY PUTTING
THE FINDS MORE THREATENING MORE
RISK.
BUT DO THEY HAVE THAT MAYBE
ABILITY RIGHT NOW LOOK AT THE
LOOK AT THESE BILLS RIGHT NOW
CRAIG DO IN THEIR DIRECTIVES
ALREADY ASKED THEM --
TO WHERE CODIFYING IT.
OKAY BUT SO IT'S NOT YOU KNOW
IT'S A IT'S A IT'S NOT A IT IT
IS NOWHERE NEAR AS INTRUSIVE IS
WHAT YOU'RE JUST.
NOT EVEN BROUGHT IT'S NOT EVEN
CLOSE.
BUT MY MY SHOES JUST INTERNET
OPENED THE DOOR TO TAKE A PEEK
AT IT BUT I GUESS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IN TALKING THE
FOLKS OVER CALPERS THEY DON'T
ABILITY DO THAT RIGHT NOW.
THE BOARD CAN DO THAT IF THEY SO.
DESIRE WISH THAT'S RIGHT
[inaudible]
OKAY --
INCLUDE QUESTIONS.
I AM WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SLUICES
ON CALL A KID HOW I FEEL IT'S
CLOSED THEN UP AT VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS AND I I
WOULD HOPE THAT THE MEMBERS THIS
COMMITTEE WE SHARE THOSE THOSE
TYPES OF CONCERNS BUT I ALL I
WILL.
SAY IS THAT --
YOU KNOW IN THE END OF THE DAY
THIS IS A A CHANGING DYNAMIC
GLOBALLY.
AND I WOULD JUST GO BACK TO MY
EXAMPLE AND YOU KNOW GIVEN THE
REALITY OF THESE RISKS.
WE HAVE TO RETHINK.
BEACH FRONT PROPERTY IN MIAMI
YEAH AT IT AND I WOULD WANT ARE
OUR LOVE WOULD WANT OUR FUND
MANAGERS TO BE THINKING ABOUT.
THE LONG TERM IMPACT OF OF A
OCEAN LEVEL RISE IN AND ALL
SORTS OF REGULATORY AND PHYSICAL
AYE RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
REALITY OF CLIMATE CHANGE OVER
THE LONG TERM FEAR OF NOT
UNDERSTAND THAT ABSOLUTELY.
THAT ALL IN ALL WE'RE DOING HERE
WITH NO AND THEN THE TOUGH PART
IS A LOT OF CITIZENS DO DRIVE.
VEHICLES THAT USE GASOLINE MOST
MY RESIDENTS DO THEY CAN AFFORD
WHAT YOUR VEHICLE THAT CAN
AFFORD SOLAR ORGAN AND THE I
LOOK I LOOK AROUND AND
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT PEOPLE ARE
BLACK AND BROWN.
I DON'T SEE I DON'T SEE SOLAR --
CELLS IS THIS TO SPUR TREE WE
JUST BOUGHT A USED DVD FOR
ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS AND AND
AND THE PRICE WILL CONTINUE.
TO IS A GREAT CARDS WORK REALLY
WELL FOR US OKAY RATE SALUTE
WILL HADN'T WE CAN DO ALL.
WHAT'S ON YOUR MOTION.
A MOVIE ITEM [inaudible] TO
COOLEY.
THE MOTION PLEASE.
OKAY.
OUTLETS LIKE IN THAT.
THANK YOU MEMBERS [inaudible]
LOCAL POLICE.
HE THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
ALLEN BRO [inaudible]
BRUNO.
CERVANTES COOLEY [inaudible]
COOLEY AYE.
COOPER THE VOTING.
COOPER NOT VOTING O'DONNELL.
BELONG THOSE LOCAL PICK YOU
THANK YOU.
NEXT UP IS THERE MORE LUCK S. B.
SIX BY.
SIX GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
[inaudible]
CHAIR [inaudible]
BLUEBOOK [inaudible]
BUT FROM.
IF IT IS A LOT OF WORK IN THIS
BILL -- S.
B. SIX FIFTY SIX IS AN ATTEMPT
TO MODIFY A RETIREMENT PLAN THAT
HAS FALLEN SHORT AND PROVIDING
AN APPROPRIATE INCOMPARABLE
RETIREMENT SYSTEM FOR THOSE
SERVING.
OUR STATE WITH DILIGENCE ON THE
BENCH IN THE JUDICIARY.
COLLEAGUES IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR A SECOND TIER PENSION PLAN
WAS ESTABLISHED FOR NEW JUDGE'S
KNOWN AS J. R. AS TO JUDGE
RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
TO MAKE IT AS A HYBRID DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION DEFINED BENEFIT
PENSION PLAN.
AND IT HAS COMPONENTS THAT WITH
THE BENEFIT OF HINDSIGHT LOOKS
LIKE THE PLAN THAT WAS CREATED
BY COMMITTEE.
THE NET RESULT THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH IS THE ONLY PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE GROUP NOT IN A BONAFIDE.
DEFINED BENEFIT PLAN.
AS A LONG TIME.
DEFINED BENEFIT PENSION PLAN
REFORMER I HAD TO CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
OUT WHEN WE STARTED THIS PROCESS
LAST YEAR THE FIRST.
IS THE PRINCIPLE OF NO BETTER NO
WORSE.
THE STATE SUPERIOR COURT JUDGES
CANNOT OBTAIN THE DEFINED
BENEFIT UNLESS THEY HAVE WORKED
TWENTY YEARS AND REACH AGE.
SIXTY FIVE THOSE STARTING BEFORE
THE AGE OF FORTY FIVE MUST WORK
EXTRA YEARS.
THOSE APPOINTED AFTER FORTY FIVE
MINUTES WORK PAST AGE SIXTY FIVE
OR TO AGE.
SEVENTY DOES NOT MEETING THESE
PECULIAR REQUIREMENTS WILL
RECEIVE THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS BACK
PLUS INTEREST PLUS A STATE
MANDATED 10% MATCH.
THEREFORE IF HEALTH CONCERNS
ARISE.
THE JUDGE IS NOT REELECTED.
WHICH THEY ARE UP EVERY SIX
YEARS IF A SPOUSE NEEDS CRITICAL
ATTENTION AND THE JUDGE.
NEEDS TO THE HUSBAND NEEDS TO
STOP AND PAY ATTENTION TO THE
SPOUSE OR IF A JUDGE DIES
PREMATURELY THEN THE JUDGE AND
FAMILY HAVE A MORE DIFFICULT
QUANDARY.
THAT THE JUDGE FIGHTING CANCER
CONTINUE TO WORK TO REACH TWENTY
YEARS ARE.
EIGHT SEVENTY THIS IS NOT AN
APPROPRIATE LEASE INCENTIVIZE
SYSTEM.
AND IF EQUALITY IS ARE BUZZWORD
HERE THEN SOMETHING MUST BE DONE.
THE SECOND CONCERN FOR THE
CERTIFIED PUBLIC ACCOUNTANTS
CERTIFIED FINANCIAL PLANNER WITH
COST.
OTHER MODIFICATIONS HAD TO BE AS
COST NEUTRAL AS POSSIBLE.
ACCORDING TO A DECEMBER ELEVENTH
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ACTUARIAL COST
ANALYSIS BY CALPERS S. B. SIX
FIVE SIX WOULD COST WOULD ONLY
COST TWO TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
IN THE FIRST YEAR.
ACCORDING TO THAT REPORT THE
TWENTY YEAR PERIOD ESTIMATED. TO
BE ABOUT NINETEEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION OR ROUGHLY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN
JANUARY ON THE TWENTY THIRD IN
THERE MEMO FOR THE FINANCE BILL
ANALYSIS STATED.
GENERAL FUND COSTS ARE EXPECTED
TO BE UP UNDER 1-000-420-1819
EIGHT HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY AND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE THOUSAND
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE COLLEAGUES
THIS IS NOT COST NEUTRAL BUT IT
COMES AWFULLY CLOSE.
AND WE CAN NEGOTIATED DOWN.
IF IF NECESSARY BUT FOR ALL THE
GOOD THIS EFFORT WILL ACCOMPLISH
THIS COST IS A WORTHWHILE
INVESTMENT IN WRITING IRAN.
COLLEAGUES I HAVE A FEW
SIGNATURES.
OF SUPPORT FROM OUR JUDGES
[inaudible]
YOUR REPORT SAYS I HAVE A FEW
BUT I GOT OVER SIX HUNDRED
SIGNATURES I'D LIKE [inaudible]
TO POPE.
IT STARTED HANDLES OUT TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PLEASE
[inaudible]
AT SENATOR RICARDO LARA IS A
JOINT AUTHORED.
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BRO IN
COOLEY ARE CO AUTHORS AND I
THANK THEM.
AND I HAVE.
A REQUEST AFTER MORE TO BE TO BE
ADDED ON THE LIST THAT YOU.
BECAUSE WE MAY TAKE AN AMENDMENT
AND APPROACHED --
I WANT EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE
CALPERS FOR ITS ASSISTANCE IN
PROVIDING AMENDMENTS TO THIS
BILL.
THEY'VE ASKED FOR ONE MORE
TECHNICAL TRY I WILL HOPE TO
MAKE AN APPROACH.
BUT THIS BILL IT HAD NO
OPPOSITION AND SINCE A STRONG
SIGNAL TO THE JUDICIARY BRANCH
THAT IT IS APPRECIATED.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE AND I HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
OKAY WHAT MOTION A SECOND WHEN
THIS IS A SUPPORT.
WELL GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
LAURIE DAMELIN A JUDGE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WITH THE SUPERIOR
COURT.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY THOUGHTS
AS A NEW JUDGE ON S. B..
SIX FIFTY SIX AM HERE TODAY NOT
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
SACRAMENTO SUPERIOR COURT FOR ON
BEHALF OF ANY PARTICULAR
ORGANIZATION BUT AS AN
INDIVIDUAL JUDGE.
I'M SEEING THIS THROUGH THE
PRISM OF MY OWN EXPERIENCE AS A
MOTHER AS A WIFE A PERSON
COMMITTED TO SERVING IN PUBLIC
SERVICE FOR MANY YEARS TO COME --
I FEEL PRIVILEGED TO HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED JUST DIED JUST LAST
YEAR AND I REALLY SINCERELY HOPE
THAT I HAVE THE NEXT TWENTY FIVE
PLUS YEARS TO SERVE BUT WE ALL
KNOW THAT THINGS HAPPEN.
AND DON'T ALWAYS GO AS EXPECTED
IN THIS BILL REALLY ADDRESSES
THAT REALITY.
I'M CONSIDER FOR EXAMPLE JUDGE
STEVE PERK WHO EFFORT WAS FROM
ORANGE COUNTY WHO WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH PANCREATIC CANCER AT AGE
SIXTY THREE AND HAD BEEN ON THE
BENCH. FOR NINETEEN YEARS --
DOCTORS GAVE HIM FOR SIX MONTHS
TO LIVE FORTUNATELY HE LIVED
LONGER THAN NOT THEY WERE WRONG
BUT AT THE TIME HE KNEW HE HAD
TO SURVIVE TO THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE TO GET A DEFINED BENEFIT
FOR HIS WIFE --
A DISABILITY RETIREMENT WAS
WORTH ABOUT A THIRD OF THE
DEFINED BENEFIT PAYOUT HE HAD
BEEN COUNTING ON FOR HIS
FAMILY'S FINANCIAL SECURITY.
AS WELL AS HE WAS OF S. B. SIX
FIFTY SIX HAD BEEN LAW AT THE
TIME HE WOULD HAVE LAUGHED WHEN
HE REACHED TWENTY YEARS OF
SERVICE AND ASSURE HIS WIFE OF
FINANCIAL SECURITY.
BUT AS IT IS HIM PUTTING NEARLY
A FULL YEAR AND THEY'LL HEALTH
AFTER HIS TWENTY YEARS OF AND AT
ITS TWENTY YEAR ANNIVERSARY AS A
JUDGE JUST TO AVOID LEAVING
HIMSELF AND HIS WIFE.
WITH LESS THAN HALF OF THE
DEFINED BENEFIT THEY WERE
COUNTING ON THIS IS NOT THE ONLY
JUDGE TO SEPARATE THIS KIND OF
EXPERIENCE AND IT WON'T BE THE
ONLY JUDGE AND CERTAINLY THIS
COULD HAPPEN TO ANYONE --
AS THE NEWLY APPOINTED JUDGE I
CAN TELL YOU THAT I'M AWARE OF A
NUMBER OF VERY HIGHLY WELL
QUALIFIED --
LAWYERS IN THE COMMUNITY YOUNG
AND DIVERSE LAWYERS WHO WOULD
WHO MIGHT CONSIDER A JUDGESHIP
BUT SEE THIS LACK OF SECURITY AS
AN IMPEDIMENT TO PURSUING A
JUDGESHIP.
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE YOU DON'T
SEE THIS KIND OF CLIFF VESTING
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR NOT EVEN
IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR --
THIS LEGISLATION AS YOU'VE HEARD
IS A VERY VERY MODEST FIX THAT
WOULD HAVE A PROFOUND IMPACT --
ON THE LIVES OF MY COLLEAGUES
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL DECADES
AND IN LIGHT OF THAT FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY. THREE I
THOUGHT I KNEW.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON CAN'T HAMLIN A
JUDGE FOR THE PRESIDENT'S
PARACORD THE DIRECTOR OF THE
ALLIANCE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
SPONSOR.
FOR SIX FIFTY SIX ADD THE
JUDICIAL FAIRNESS ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I WANT THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS YOU.
I WILL KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF
UNLIKE THE LAWYERS WHO APPEAR IN
MY COURT ALL MAKE GOOD ON THAT
PROMISE -- I
AS JUDGE HIM WELL POINTED OUT
THERE ARE TRAGEDIES --
WITH I'LL ADD ONE MORE IT'S A
GENTLEMAN SOUTH OF WHERE I AM IN
TULARE COUNTY APPALLED BOARDMAN.
A JUDGE MORGAN WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH METASTATIC CANCER AT AGE --
SIXTY NINE HE KNEW THAT IF HE
LAUGHED AND TOOK BACK HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS PLUS INTEREST IT
WOULD LEAVE HIS WIFE VERY LITTLE.
FOR HER SECURITY.
AND SO HE DRAGGED HIMSELF INTO
WORK EVERYDAY UNTIL HE REACHED
HIS SEVENTIETH BIRTHDAY SO HE
COULD RETIRE AND PREVENT SECURE
THAT BENEFIT FOR HER FORTY DAYS
LATER.
NOW THERE IS NO REASON FOR THAT
COURT TO SUFFER.
THE LOSS OF HIS ABILITIES TO
SERVE BOMBING I'M SURE HE DID
HIS BEST BUT HOW MUCH CAN ONE DO
IN ITS STATE.
AND SO THE COURT HAD TO PICK UP
THE SLACK AND CERTAINLY WAS A
TRAGIC EXPERIENCE FOR HIM HIS
WIFE TO WONDER IF HE WOULD EVEN
MAKE IT TO THAT FINISH LINE.
I'M.
I KNOW YOU'VE ALREADY MISTER
BOLTON'S ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL
IT'S THOROUGH AT SIX IT IT
EXPLAINS ALL OF THE BEST
ARGUMENTS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT ARGUMENT TO
MAKE IS THAT UNDER THIS BILL NO
JUDGE GETS A DOLLAR MORE OR A
DOLLAR A DAY SOONER.
THAN THEY WOULD GET IF THEY
STAYED ON UNTIL FINAL RETIREMENT
AGE.
IT'S SIMPLY ALLOWS THE JUDGE TO
GET THE YEARS OF SERVICE THAT
JUDGE HAS ACTUALLY SERVED.
AT A LATER DATE.
I AND ACTUALLY FORGO SOME
INCREASES THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE
OTHERWISE RECEIVED SOME JUDGES
WILL TAKE LESS SOME WILL GET THE
BENEFIT AT A LATER DATE THAT HAD
THEY STAYED ON THE BENCH.
A IT'S A VERY SMALL ASK BUT I
THINK IT ADDRESSES THE MOST
TRAGIC CIRCUMSTANCES.
THAT ARE BROUGHT ABOUT BY THE
CLIFF VESTING FEATURE OF THIS
BILL.
SO ICE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
BUTTONS.
FOR THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING I'M JUDGE MARIANNE
GILLIARD I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU [inaudible]
IF YOU.
JUDGE ELIZABETH WITH IT I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THINKING
[inaudible]
HELLO.
JUDGE US IN THOSE IN SUPPORT AND
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER HAD FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
GOOD MORNING I'M JUDGE STEVE
WHITE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA JUDGES
AND OF COURSE I SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
I'M JUDGE JOHN ADAMS MARCH
COUNTY ALSO ALLIANCE DIRECTOR
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND I THINK THOSE WHO HAVE
HELPED US THIS FAR.
JUDGE THOMAS LONG LOS ANGELES I
ALSO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE
BELOW IT SPEAKING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION WE
AGREE THIS IS A WORTHY
INCREMENTAL IMPROVEMENT IN THE
J. HEIRESS UP PROGRAM AND WE
APPLAUD SENATOR FOR HIS HARD
WORK ON IT.
BUT HE IS CERTAINLY CORRECT THAT
JUDGES RETIREMENT SYSTEM IS A
REALLY UNIQUE.
PROGRAM WITHIN --
THE STATE SYSTEM IT IS THE ONLY
HYBRID PROGRAM THAT I KNOW OF
ANYWHERE IN PUBLIC SERVICE WHERE
YOU HAVE A DEFINED CONTRIBUTION
UNTIL THE EXACT MOMENT OF
VESTING.
AT WHICH CASE YOU CONTRIBUTE YOU
CHANGE TO A DEFINED BENEFIT.
IT ALSO IS THE ONLY SYSTEM I
KNOW OF THAT HAS THIS SORT OF
CLIFF VESTING.
A THAT SORT OF CLIFF VESTING IS
ACTUALLY ILLEGAL IN PRIVATE
PLANS SO THIS IMPROVEMENT IS
IMPORTANT AND IT'S WORTHY --
THERE HAS BEEN QUESTION AND AND
SO THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION HAS A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION THERE HAVE BEEN
VARIOUS ABOUT COST ESTIMATES
ABOUT THE PLAN OVERTIME AND THEY
HAVE.
VARIED WILDLY.
A AT THE PRESENT TIME --
WE BELIEVE --
THE ACTUARIAL COST IS THESE
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND TO A
MILLION PER YEAR --
THE SPONSORS HAVE INDICATED THAT
NO -- POSED
PEPPERIDGE JUDGE SHOULD HAVE
THEIR RETIREMENT CONTRIBUTION
INCREASED BECAUSE OF THE
ENACTMENT OF THIS BILL.
THE OTHER UNIQUE THING ABOUT
JUDGES PENSION LAW UNDER PEPPER.
IS THIS ONE HALF OF NORMAL COST
OBLIGATION ON NEW PEPPERIDGE
JUDGES.
HAS THE HIGHEST EMPLOYEE
CONTRIBUTION I'M AWARE OF IN THE
STATE SYSTEM IT IS PRESENTLY
SIXTEEN POINT 75% OF SALARY
[inaudible]
WHICH IS FAR HIGHER THAN ANY
OTHER EMPLOYEES THAT I KNOW OF
SO WE'RE VERY SENSITIVE ABOUT
THE APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
JUDGES WHO COULD SEE THAT
SIXTEEN POINT 75% GO UP.
AND WE HAVE ASKED FOR
CLARIFICATION THAT THEIR
CONTRIBUTION WOULD NOT BE
INCREASED AS A RESULT OF THE
[inaudible]
WHICH WOULD [inaudible]
IMPLEMENT THE A STATEMENT MADE
BY THE SPONSORS THAT NO POST
PEPPER JUDGE WOULD PAY MORE FOR
THIS BENEFIT.
IF THAT AMENDMENT IS INCLUDED
WE'D BE DELIGHTED TO SUPPORT THE
BILL AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
NO SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT SPEAKERS
OPPOSITION.
LOCAL PUBLIC COMMENT FIRST
OLYMPIC CENTER FOR BEING THIS
BILL FORWARD PAID SO MUCH NEED
TO FIX THAT MAYES JUST A SECOND
A COUNTY.
THE OPTION TO WORK WITH AND
DEATHLY UNDERSTAND THEIR PLIGHT.
AND THEIR ISSUES.
INCOME IS THE COMMITTEE MISTER
BROKE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER --
CENTER MORLOCK THANKS FOR YOUR
HARD WORK ON THIS THIS HAD BEEN
TRIED BEFORE AND THE THE PICK UP
WAS ALWAYS SENATE PERSONA THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN YOUR
HARD WORK WITH SARAH LAUREN
GETTING INTO SENATE PURSE --
ALSO LIKE SAY HELLO TO MY FRIEND
AND FORMER DANA POINT RESIDENT
JUDGE JOHN ADAMS FOR HIS HARD
WORK THIS IS BEEN SEVERAL YEARS
IN THE MAKING AND THANKS FOR ALL
YOUR EFFORTS AND I'M PROUD TO BE
A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR ON THIS
BILL.
IT KNOW FOR THE COMMENTS THAT WE
INCLUDE CLOSING COMMENTS THANK
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
THANK YOU ASSUMING BROKE FOR
BEING ENCOURAGE YOUR FROM THE
GET GO --
WHEN THIS STARTED LAST YEAR?
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT --
COLLEAGUES I I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE REQUEST FOR AN
AMENDMENT --
WHEN YOU HAVE TWO HUNDRED JUDGES
THAT R. J. ARRESTS ONE AND THEN
YOU HAVE?
ROUGHLY THIRTEEN HUNDRED BETTER
CHERISH TO IN ANOTHER TWO
HUNDRED BETTER POST PEPPER THAT
ARE NEW --
WHEN THE ACTUARIES I DO THE?
CALCULATION OF THE CONTRIBUTION --
I CERTAINLY EMPATHIZE WITH THE
FACT THAT WE NEED TO PROTECT THE
POST PEPPER JUDGES --
WE WORK WITH CALPERS YESTERDAY
AFTERNOON AFTER THIS ISSUE WAS.
BROUGHT TO US AND THEY'RE A
LITTLE RELUCTANT TO MAKE ANY
RECOMMENDED CHANGES.
IN THAT THE BILL AS IT IS A IT
WOULD BE VERY HARD TO TELL
ACTUARY HOW TO MAKE SOME
CALCULATIONS --
SO THAT'S WHY I'M [inaudible]
SORT OF NOT GOING THE AMENDMENT
ROUTE I'M KIND OF SAYING THIS IS
LESS THAN A MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR.
IT WAS A LOT BIGGER WHEN WE
STARTED WE HAD A LIABILITY THAT
WAS OVER THREE HUNDRED MILLION
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
ACTUARIES AT CALPERS AN EXTERNAL.
AND SO I I BELIEVE THAT THE
GOVERNOR I SHOULD BE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE THIS COST WE'VE JUST
GIVEN SOME GET FUNDING TO THE TO
THE JUDICIARY BRANCH IN THIS
CURRENT BUDGET THAT WAS APPROVED
LAST WEEK.
AND WE'RE ALSO DOING A WHOLE LOT
FOR THE MENTALLY ILL AND THE
HOMELESS I I WOULD THINK THAT --
WE SHOULD BE REFLECTIVE OF WHO'S
REALLY WORKING HARD MAKING OUR
JUDICIAL SYSTEM WORK AND FOR FOR
THIS SMALL AND A MODIFICATION
WE'RE GIVING A BIG INCENTIVE. TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE IF YOU DON'T
PAY THEM YOU DISCOURAGE THEM
THEY DON'T FEEL APPRECIATED IN
THIS IS A A GLORIOUS OPPORTUNITY
I JUST THINK WE SHOULD.
TAKE CARE OF IT ALL ONCE AND FOR
ALL IN THE BUDGET AND MAKE A
STRONG STATEMENT OF SUPPORT
PROJECTED SO THANK YOU.
AND I ASK REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
LOCAL POLICE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
GROW BY.
BROUGH AYE CERVANTES.
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER AYE.
COOPER I O'DONNELL.
YOU BILLS UNCLE SENATOR.
THE COMMISSION CHAIRED EVERY
FIGURE TIME DOCTOR PASSED THE
BACK WE WE MISSED ONE ITEM.
SENATE BILL FIFTEEN ALL.
FOR BUT AS I THOUGHT IT WAS ON
SETUP.
IT'S COMMITTEE BILL SENATE PURRS
COMMITTEE BILL --
SP FIFTEEN A FOR IS SENATE PURGE
COMMITTEE HOUSEKEEPING BILL THAT
MAKES TECHNICAL NON
CONTROVERSIAL CONFORMING CHANGES
TO CLEAN UP SECTIONS.
OF THE GOVERNMENT CODE
ADMINISTERED BY CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT HEALTH HUMAN RESOURCES.
I I GUESS YOU CAN SEE ANALYSIS
WHAT MODIFICATIONS WERE MADE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT IT.
THANK YOU WHEN IS A SUPPORT.
WHEN HIS OPPOSITION [inaudible]
CLOSING.
RESPECT WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS MAY REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
WROTE [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
I COOPER I O'DONNELL.
THE BILL'S UNCLE.
SEE MR THURMAN'S JOINED US.
EIJI ARE.
FORTY ONE I THINK MISTER CHAIR.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS IN HERE PRESENT AJ ARE
FORTY ONE OF THIS RESOLUTION.
CALLS ON CONGRESS AND THE
PRESIDENT TO REDUCE OR TO REPEAL
OFFSETS [inaudible]
THAT REDUCE SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFITS. FOR THOSE WHO HAE
EARNED THEM THESE OFFSETS.
ARE CALLED THE GOVERNMENT
PENSION OFFSET.
AND THE WINDFALL ELIMINATION
PROVISION --
AND THEY ESSENTIALLY REDUCE OF
SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS FOR
SCHOOL TEACHERS PEACE OFFICERS.
AND FIREFIGHTERS ARE MANY WHO
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR COMMUNITY.
AND MANY WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR SO
CURATOR EITHER THROUGH EARLIER
SERVICE IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
AND WHO ARE SURPRISED TO FIND
OUT THAT THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFITS WILL BE REDUCED FOR
THEM -- OR
FOR THEIR DEPENDENTS IN SOME
CASES REDUCE BY AS MUCH AS TWO
THIRDS.
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY WERE A
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE IN ANOTHER
SYSTEM A CLEARLY THESE
IMPEDIMENTS ARE ARE IMPEDIMENTS
TO OUR ABILITY A TO RECRUIT.
AND RETAIN A PUBLIC EMPLOYEES IN
OUR SCHOOLS A PIECE OFFICES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR US TO A CLOSE THE
SHORTAGES --
THAT EXISTS AND THATCAN
UNDERMINE OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
GREAT EDUCATION AND SAFE
COMMUNITIES REPEALING THESE
PROVISIONS WILL ADDRESS THE
SHORTEST AND RESTORE FAIRNESS.
FOR FAMILIES THAT DEPEND ON
THESE BENEFITS UPON.
RETIREMENT I WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE A CONTEXT --
IS YVONNE CARDIO WHO'S FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND JENNIFER
BAKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IBOOK.
THANK YOU WHEN IS A SPORT GOOD
MORNING JENNIFER BAKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORTER THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION --
FOR QUITE A NUMBER OF YEARS
WE'VE BEEN BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION FORWARD TO MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE TRUCK TO TRY TO
GET CONGRESS AND PRESIDENT TO
CHANGE AT THIS.
DISCRIMINATORY ACTION FOR
KALISTO WHOSE MEMBERS DAIS --
THESE TO FEDERAL OFFSETS
REPRESENT CLEAR GENDER BIAS AND
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST WOMEN AS
72% OF CALCIUM AS MEMBERS ARE
WOMEN SO I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
MANY -- VERY
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD
WITH RETIREES WHO OFTEN FIND OUT
AS THEY RETIRED THAT THE CAT
THAT THE SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFITS THAT THEY WERE COUNTING
ON ARE NOT ONLY GOING TO BE
REDUCED.
UP OFTEN THEM WHEN THEY LOSE
THEIR SPOUSE.
THEN THOSE REDUCTIONS ARE REDUCE
OR IN FACT OFTEN ELIMINATED AS
WELL THIS HAS A MASSIVE ECONOMIC
IMPACT ON RETIREES AND AS YOU
KNOW WOMEN HAVE OFTEN NOT HAD.
EQUAL REPRESENTATION WHEN IT
COMES TO EQUALITY IN RETIREMENT
AND SO WE SEE THE ELIMINATION OF
THOSE SOCIAL SECURITY OFF SAID
SOMETHING THAT WILL HAVE.
A MAJOR IMPACT IN KEEPING OUR
RETIRED SECURE ECONOMIC FUTURE
IN OUR SHARED SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MR CHEN MEMBER THE
BOND COMPANY WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS SOMEONE BEGIN BY
THANKING A SUPPLEMENT THURMOND
FOR AUTHORING THIS MEASURE.
AS I TRAVEL UP AND DOWN THE
STATE THE THE ISSUE OF THE
WEAPON IN GPO COME UP FREQUENTLY.
THEY COME UP IN THE CONTEXT OF
JUST ONE ADDITIONAL FACTOR THAT
MAKES IT HARD TO RECRUIT ME AND
RETAIN TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS --
BUT IN AND SIMILARLY TO SET MY
COLLEAGUE JENNIFER.
BAKER WAS HE TI THE COME UP IN
THE IN THE CONTEXT OF VERY
DIFFICULT PERSONAL CONVERSATIONS
IN TERMS OF HOW.
THESE OFFSETS IMPACT ON FOLKS ON
ON A PERSONAL MATTER --
ADJUSTED TO SHARE ONE QUICK
STORY TO ILLUSTRATE THE IMPACT
ON HOW I WAS TALKING WITH A
RETIRED MEMBER JUST YESTERDAY.
BY THE NAME OF MARGARET MARKETED
MARKET WITH THE TWENTY SIX YEAR
EDUCATE OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM TEACHER AND ADMINISTRATOR.
AND SHE ALSO WORKED TWELVE YEARS
IN HIGHER EDUCATION AND PRIVATE
INDUSTRY.
WHERE SHE WAS PUTTING INTO
SOCIAL SECURITY?
HOW MUCH SHE STARTS COLLECTING
ON THAT SOCIAL SECURITY --
NEXT YEAR ON TO HER OFFSET HER
HER REDUCTION IN ITS OF SECURITY
BENEFIT WILL BE NEARLY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
IT'S FORCING HER TO TO CONSIDER
SELLING HOUSE THAT SHE ZONED FOR
FOR DECADES AND RAISE THE KIDS
AND IT'S FOUR SEN ATKINS CENTER
HEALTH CARE OPTIONS THAT THAT
AND TO CHANGE OUR HEALTHCARE.
ON COVERAGE --
AND UNFORTUNATELY STORIES ARE
NOT UNIQUE --
THESE THESE --
OFFSETS NEED TO BE REPEALED
AGAIN WE THINK THE ASSEMBLYMAN
UP THERE IN THE MEASURE AND AND
NOT VOTER SUPPORT.
WHEN ALL SUPPORT?
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS BRIAN HOW WITH
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WERE A STRONG SUPPORT
THAT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
RETIRED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING REBEKAH CURLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RETIRED
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
STEPHANIE DOT WITH THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
TED TOP AND FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE RETIREES IN STRONG SUPPORT
WE THINK CARE ASSEMBLYMAN FRENCH.
TO LIKE ANYONE ELSE SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANYONE OPPOSITION --
BRING BACK UP TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY --
COMETS.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
AND SOME REMEMBER LIKE ECLIPSE
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK HER MUCH GOOD BILL MCINNIS
PORTERS WELL SOSECRETARY CAN
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED.
RODRIGUEZ ARE OUR BIGGEST AYE
ALLEN.
BROUGH [inaudible]
CERVANTES COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I O'DONNELL.
WELL PLACED ON CALL THANK READ
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
[inaudible]
THE CALENDAR
.
SHE PULLS BECAUSE GET THAT OUT.
THEY OFFER.
NOTHING HELD [inaudible]
ON SHE BUT I MENTION NICOLAS
OPENS A CRACK [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible] TO TRY.
I HEARD SUPPORT.
WHERE CURLY WAITING FOR US
SENATOR [inaudible]
SKINNER.
SHOP SAWS WE WAIT.
SHOULD TAKE OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SECRETARY UNKNOWN OR
WE'RE DEGENERATE OKAY
[inaudible]
WE'RE GOOD [inaudible]
TROPICAL OVER [inaudible]
YEAH.
WE'RE JUST GONNA DO EVERY
.
WE ONLY NEED
FOR IN THE BILL IS.
GOVERNOR'S NUMBER.
SEVEN THIS LAST
[inaudible]
ONE YEAH.
SENATOR THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE OUR LAST RULED THAT
THE DAY --
FOUGHT NUMBER SEVEN S. B. TEN
EIGHTY FIVE SENATOR.
THE MIKE IS YOURS THANK YOU I'M
CHAIRED VERY PREACHED TO OF OF
IN COLLEGES FOR THE COMMITTEE.
THE DELAY --
MY MAYOR OF ONE OF MY MY LARGEST
CITY IS PRESENTING ON A BILL IN
THE COMMITTEE I WAS SITTING AND
SO.
ANYWAY.
I'M SP TEN EIGHTY FIVE
RECOGNIZES THAT.
WE HAVE --
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES WHO ALSO HAVE
RULES IN THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING UNITS THAT THEY ARE
MEMBERS OF SO OFTEN THEY ARE THE
STEWARDS FOR THAT UNION OR
ANOTHER RULE.
AND THAT IT REQUIRES THEM AT
TIMES TO TAKE OFF TIME FROM
THEIR REGULAR JOBS TO PERFORM
THEIR UNION DUTIES
AND SO WHAT S. B. TEN EIGHTY
FIVE DOES IS ENSURE THAT.
THOSE EMPLOYEES CAN RECEIVE A
LEAVE OF ABSENCE WHICH THE UNION
PAYS FOR COVERS ALL COSTS.
AND THEN THAT THE REINSTATEMENT
WOULD OCCUR WHEN THEY'RE
COMPLETE THEIR DUTIES WITHOUT
LOSS OF SENIORITY.
AND I IT ALSO HOLDS THE AND
EMPLOYER HARMLESS SO IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT OCCURS WHILE THE
EMPLOYEES DURING THEIR UNION
DUTIES.
THE EMPLOYERS NOT HELD LIABLE
THEIR HELD HARMLESS.
AND US OF THE STUDENT ADDRESSES
WHAT SOME.
EMPLOYERS HAVE BEEN CONCERNED
ABOUT IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO
GRANT THOSE --
EMPLOYEES THEIR ABILITY TO DO
THEIR UNION DUTY SO WITH THAT I
ASPIRO VOTING MY WITNESS MICHELE
KESTLER FROM SEIU GOOD SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE CAST THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF.
JUST WANT TO SAY A FEW THINGS
CURRENT LAW.
CURRENTLY ALLOWS EMPLOYEES THE
RIGHT TO FORM JOIN AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE ACTIVITIES OF
THEIR EMPLOYEES ORGANIZATION.
BUT THAT RIGHT IS THWARTED ONE
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS REFUSED TO
ALLOW THEM TO HAVE TIME OFF --
AS SENATOR SKINNER SAID THIS
BILL REALLY IS BUILT OFF OF THE
A LAW THAT WAS ENACTED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THE
PROVIDES US RIGHT TO SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES AND ALL IT DOES IS
PROVIDE THE SAME RIGHTS TO OTHER
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES --
LAST POINT IS THE OPPOSITION IS
GOING TO COME UP HERE AND
CONTEND THAT THIS BILL TAKES
AWAY IMPORTANT MEASURES FROM THE
BARGAINING PROCESS. TO THE
DETRIMENT OF PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
COMMUNITIES. TWO POINTS ON THAT
FIRST THERE ARE LITERALLY
HUNDREDS OF PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT
HAVE ALREADY AGREED TO THESE
TYPES OF LEAVES AND NOBODY HAS
BEEN HARMED COMMUNITIES HAVE NOT
BEEN HARMED SERVICES HAVE NOT
BEEN HARMED HARMED --
THEY REALLY ONLY HAVE ISSUE WITH
ONE MATTER COMING OUT OF THE
BARGAINING PROCESS AND THAT'S
THEIR VETO AUTHORITY.
THEY HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH TWO
OTHER ISSUES COMING OUT OF THE
BARGAINING PROCESS AND THAT IS
WHAT THEY CURRENTLY HAVE TO ASK
FOR A US IN THE BARGAINING
PROCESS AND THAT'S TO FULLY
REIMBURSED FOR THE COST OF
EMPLOYEES TIME WHILE THEY'RE ON
LEAVE.
AND TO INDEMNIFY THEM WE
PROVIDED BOTH OF THOSE THINGS IN
THIS BILL --
AGAIN ALL THIS BILL DOES IS GIVE
THESE EMPLOYMENT EMPLOYEES EQUAL
TREATMENT TO OTHER EMPLOYEES WE
ASK FREE AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THINK ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
MARK CHAIR MEMBERS RANGE FROM
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION I'M OUR MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN I GREATLY IMPACTED --
ON THIS ISSUE.
WE'VE BEEN A FOR THE LAST THIRTY
YEARS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO TAKE
THE TIME OFF TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
UNION DUTIES. FOR OUR MEMBERS
AND TIME UNTIL RECENTLY JUST
ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF AGO BOMB
OUR SHERIFF DECIDED THAT HE
WANTED TO NOT DO THAT ANYMORE
AND JUST HAD ELIMINATED.
AND THIS IS BECAUSE OUR
EMPLOYEES TO NOW HAVE TO BURN
THEIR OWN TIME. TO DO THEIR
UNION DAVIES EVEN THOUGH THE
UNION HAS ALWAYS PAID. FOR THOSE
SAME ACTIVITIES AND THERE'S
NEVER ANY COST THIS WAS A RESULT
OF SOME POLITICAL DIFFERENCES
THAT ARE ASSOCIATION AND OUR
SHERIFF OF HAD.
AND TARA WERE BEING A WE'RE
BEING HARMED AS A RESULT AND SO
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
LAST YEAR I VOTE.
MIKE WE'LL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ARE ALSO HERE
STRONG SUPPORT. TO CHECK MEMBERS
PATRON WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATE REPEALING THE PEACE
OFFICERS RESEARCH ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHRISTIE BELL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT.
DILLER STRAND FLORIST ON BEHALF
OF THE COMPANY'S GOING PLACES
CESSATION IN SUPPORT.
JOSH WILL GO GO WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT NOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE OPPOSITION.
GET READY MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AGAIN DOROTHY JOHNSON THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND ALSO BEHALF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE URBAN
COUNTIES THE CALIFORNIA THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES.
AND THE ROLE COUNTY REPRESENTS
OF CALIFORNIA WHO WERE ALSO ALL
STUCK IN OTHER COMMITTEE
HEARINGS THIS MORNING.
AND WE ARE HERE RESPECTFULLY
POSE TO THE MEASURE --
AND I DO APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE OFFERED AND
THE HOLD HARMLESS PROVISIONS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY --
WE FEEL THIS BILL TIPS THE SCALE
FAR WITH THE MANDATORY --
LEAVE THAT MUST BE PROVIDED --
OUR LOCAL AGENCIES UNDERSTAND
THE NEED FOR ENGAGEMENT AND
INVOLVEMENT --
WITH THEIR REPRESENTATIVES BUT
AGAIN --
THIS CREATING NEW TYPE OF
PROTECTIVE LEAVE BUT WE THINK --
IS AB AT STEP.
TO STEP TWO PARTS USE ME.
AM I ALSO IMAGINE THIS IS NOT
CODIFYING EXISTING PRACTICES
THAT MAY BE THE CASE AND MANY
LOCAL AGENCIES BUT IT IS NOT A
STATE RIGHT PRACTICE.
AND IT DOES NOT ACTUALLY NEAR
WHAT SCHOOLS ARE REQUIRED TO DO
SCHOOLS HAVE A MANDATORY
REIMBURSEMENT FULL REIMBURSEMENT
AND WITHIN TEN DAYS --
OF THAT LEAVES SO IT'S NOT
EXACTLY MARRIED WHAT THE SCHOOLS
DO HAVE --
ARE COUNTIES ARE ESPECIALLY
CONCERNED FOR POSITIONS IN HUMAN
SERVICES IN CHILDREN'S SERVICES
DEPARTMENTS THERE FUND OF ITS
STATE AND FEDERAL DOLLARS --
UNFORTUNATELY FOR NOT ABLE TO
GET FULL REIMBURSEMENT FOR THOSE
POSITIONS THAT WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO BE PARTIALLY OFFSET BY THE
STATE OR FEDERAL DOLLARS INSTEAD
THAT WOULD COME OUT OF OUR
GENERAL FUND SO THAT'S ANOTHER
TRUCK COST.
COUNTIES AND OTHER LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE ALSO ON THE HOOK
FOR PROVIDING ACCRUED SICK LEAVE
AND VACATION TIME IS ALSO
PENSION CREDIT THAT WOULD STILL
CREW WHILE THE INDIVIDUAL WAS
OUT FOR UNION PURPOSES.
AND THEN FINALLY WE HAVE HEARD
CONCERNS FROM OUR COUNTIES ABOUT
WHEN THAT COLLATERAL COLLATERAL
WORKERS BROUGHT IN TO BACK FILL
THE POSITION WHAT HAPPENS TO
THEM AND HOW ARE THERE.
I'M RIGHTS AND ABILITIES
PRESERVED ON IF THEY WOULD LOSE
THEIR POSITION AFTER A MONTH SIX
MONTHS OR A YEAR SO. FOR THE
REASONS STATED WE RESPECTFULLY
POSES MEASURE THINK ILL.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE --
COMMENTS WIENER.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER OR WHAT
THEY CONSIDER BRING US FOR THIS
IS A OF MUCH NEEDED BILL I'VE
SEEN INACTION SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
WHICH IS WHERE LARGER COUNTIES
IN SACRAMENTO HAVE BEEN ON BOTH
ENDS OF IT AS A BARGAINING UNIT
MEMBER BUT ALSO THE MANAGER
PARTY A CONTRACT.
IT'S EFFECTIVE SILVER SO TO SAY
THAT DOESN'T WORK NO BY THAT.
IT'S A LOT EASIER TO RESOLVE
THESE ISSUES ON THE FRONT END
AND GET SOME RELEASED UNDERGONE
BARGAINING CONTRACT.
THEY GET WORK BETTER FOR
EVERYBODY SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL.
AS WE THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING FORWARD [inaudible]
AND ALLAH.
YOUR MOTIONS IN THIS MOTION
THAT'S MY MOTION YES THERE'S A
MOTION THERE'S A SECOND ANY
OTHER COMMENTS COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THAT SENATOR JIM LIKED CLOSE.
TIME I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
VOTE.
THANK FOR MUCH GOOD BILL OF
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER.
SAID ALL THE RIGHT THINGS AS
GOOD BUILDING IS SUPPORTED.
AND WITH THAT W. HAVE MOTION A
SECOND SECTOR LIKE CHOLERA.
OKAY THE MOTION IS TO PASS MARIE
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE.
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
WROTE [inaudible]
CRONO CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER [inaudible]
WELL I COOPER I O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THE MEASURES OUT
FIVE ONE THANK YOU.
SO THAT FIGURE WILL GO AHEAD AND
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS I WILL
START WITH THE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE AG ARE FORTY ONE THURMAN.
IF THE AND MOTION IS BE ADOPTED
[inaudible]
OF BRO.
A TERRIBLE TWENTY FIRST
[inaudible]
ONE CERVANTES [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
SO THAT THE MEASURES UP.
FIVE ONE THE NEXT ONE ON THE
AGENDA FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
SIX FIVE SIX MORE LOCKED.
SECRETARY CALLED THE MISSION
MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS BE PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS --
BRO.
WAIT A MINUTE [inaudible]
I BROUGH AYE.
I RODRIGUEZ AYE [inaudible]
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE AND O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THAT MEASURES OUT
SIX ZERO THE NEXT ONE IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR PAN.
S. B. SEVEN EIGHTY THREE
SECRETARY CALLED THE MISSING
MEMBERS OKAY.
OTHER MOTIONS TO PASS ME
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
OF CERVANTES.
THURMOND TO FLANK COOLEY.
THAT MEASURES OUT.
FIVE ONE NEXT ONE IS FAR NUMBER
FIVE S. B.. NINE SIXTY FIVE ON
SORRY ON NON SP SEVENTY THREE
FIVE ZERO MEASURES OUT.
OUR NEXT ONE FIVE NUMBER FIVE SP
NINE SIXTY FOUR ALLEN SECRETARY
CALLED THE MISSING MEMBERS.
MOTIONS DO PASSING RE REFER TO
PROCREATION RODRIGUEZ AYE
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ I CERVANTES.
PREVENT HIS AYE AND O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THE MEASURES OF THAT
THE MEASURES OUT. FOUR ZERO FOR
ONE I'M SORRY I'M.
NEXT ON PHAM NUMBER.
EIGHT S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
LEYVA SECRETARY CALL THE MISSING
MEMBERS [inaudible]
SOME OF WHAT I WANT.
OR HER PHONE NUMBER SIX SP TEN
TWENTY TWO PM [inaudible]
ASSERTIVENESS MEMBERS.
MOTION IS THE PAST REAR TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
AS CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE.
THAT MEASURES OUT.
SIX ZERO NEXT ONE WAS A BE
FOUGHT AND TWENTY FIVE IS UP.
THE SEVEN A SO THE NEXT ONE
WOULD GO.
TO NO ONE AT ALL.
YEAH OR DID YOUR DID.
NEXT ONE OF FOUGHT NUMBER.
NINE S. B..
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR WE'RE ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR NUMBER EIGHT I'M
SORRY PHONE NUMBER A S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR LEYVA.
SECRETARY PROBLEMS MEMBERS
MILITIAS DO PASS AND REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RODRIGUEZ AYE RODRIGUEZ AYE
ALLEN [inaudible]
BRO.
BROUGH AYE CERVANTES CERVANTES I
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER AYE AYE COOPER
AYE O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THAT MEASURES OUT.
SIX ZERO NEXT ONE FILE ITEM.
ELEVEN S. B. ELEVEN SIXTY SIX
PARA.
OR ELEVEN FORTY FOUR I'M SORRY
I'M SKIPPING WHEN THEY'RE NUMBER
NINE SB ELEVEN FORTY FOUR DOT.
SECRETARY CALLED THE MISSING
MEMBERS.
MOTION IS DO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOPER
[inaudible]
COOPER I THE MEASURES OUT.
SIX ZERO NEXT ONE FILE ITEM
NUMBER [inaudible]
ELEVEN QUIRK. TEN IS UNCONSCIOUS.
SOME SORT PHONE NUMBER ELEVEN SB-ELEVEN SIXTY SIX PAM.
SECRETARY CALL THE MISSING
MEMBERS --
DO BEST AND REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ I RODRIGUEZ I OF
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE.
THE MEASURES OUT.
FIVE ONE NEXT ONE IS FAR NUMBER
TWELVE SP ELEVEN NINETY FIVE
PORTANTINO.
SECRETARY CALLED THE MISSING
MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS THE PATH AND WE'VE
REFERRED TO APPROPRIATIONS OF
RODRIGUEZ AYE RODRIGUEZ HIGHWAY
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE.
THAT THE MEASURES OUT.
SIX ZERO NEXT ON PUMP ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN S. B. TWELVE
SIXTY ONE NELSON.
SECRETARY PROBLEMS MEMBERS OKAY
MOTION IF YOU PASS AND REFERRED
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
OF CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOPER
[inaudible]
COOPER I THE MEASURES OUT.
SIX ZERO NEXT ONE FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN S. B. THIRTEEN TWELVE
NEWMAN SECRETARY CALLED THE
MACHINE MEMBERS.
S. MOTION IS DO PASSING RE REFER
TO COMMITTEE ON VETERANS AFFAIRS
RODRIGUEZ AYE.
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN PEROT.
BROUGH AYE CERVANTES.
THURMOND IS A COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THAT MEASURES OUT.
SIX ZERO NEXT ONE FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN SB FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
NIELSEN.
SECRETARY CALL THE MISSING
MEMBERS OKAY LUSCIOUS DO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
CERVANTES.
AVENTIS I AND COOPER.
COOPER I THAT MEASURES OUT.
SIX ZERO NEXT ONE PHAM SEVENTEEN
S. B..
FIFTEEN ZERO FOUR SECRETARY
CALLED MISS MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS THE PATH AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE
RODRIGUEZ AYE A BRO.
BROUGH AYE CERVANTES.
CERVANTES I'D COOLEY
[inaudible]
COOLEY AYE [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
I'M SORRY FIFTY NO.
FOR OKAY O'DONNELL AYE
[inaudible]
PUSHED MAGNITUDE.
OF WAS IT WAS A LOOK.
THE MEASURES OUT.
SIX ZERO ALAS FROM PALM EIGHTEEN
AS CHAIR TWENTY FOUR JACKSON.
SECRETARY CALLED MISSION MEMBERS.
HE THE MOTIONS BE ADOPTED ON RE
REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ HIGH
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BRUNO CERVANTES [inaudible]
NOT VOTING [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
THE MEASURE FAILS WHEN.
ONE A WITH THAT JUST ONE MATURE
GOT HER BIG CONSENT CALENDAR.
OTHERS TWO ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
SB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE PAN.
AND FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY
BIDAK --
SECTOR CALL THE MISSING MEMBERS
OF CONSENT [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
AND RODRIGUEZ I RODRIGUEZ AYE
CERVANTES CERVANTES AYE COOLEY
AYE COOLEY AYE.
WITH THAT CONSENT IS PASSED OUT
SIX ZERO AND WITH THAT I BELIEVE
WE HAVE ALL THE ITEMS TAKEN UP
FOR TODAY.
THANK ALL MEMBERS AND THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
WITH.
WHEN?
YOU FELT [inaudible]
BUT I YEAH.
AND NOT LOOK AT THIS WITH THE
SINS OF AROUSAL.
ALRIGHT SO THE PROGRESSIVE THANK
YOU [inaudible] NINE SIX NINE
SIX NINE FIVE SORRY.
REGARDING THE MAYES WEARING
RIGHT NOW.
I THINK SO BECAUSE WE HAVE SO
MUCH MATERIAL ALLEN [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
WALDRON.
TWENTY SEE YOU NEXT WEEK.
THERE'S ONE OF THOSE WAYS
[inaudible]
I AND HEY LOOK.
THE HOUSE OF MURATSUCHI
[inaudible]
OVER [inaudible]
ONE REALLY [inaudible]
NOTHING.
WHICH ARE PRETTY WELL.
SO WE'LL SEE.
SECTION THAT WAS REMOVED
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
I LIKE.
I HAVE NOT [inaudible]
NNOVA.
PLUS AND REPUBLICANS
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THIS.
YOUR QUESTION WAS WHAT
[inaudible]
BUT LIKE PERHAPS [inaudible]
FOR IT'S HERE [inaudible]
IT'S OF 1% [inaudible]
NNOVA [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
ALL [inaudible]
GO TAKE [inaudible]
THAT'S RIGHT.
I DON'T AFTER [inaudible]
DR ROOM.
I GUESS THAT WAS [inaudible]
GREAT BARBECUE.
WHAT HE DOES IS TALK ABOUT
[inaudible]
GET [inaudible]
I THINK [inaudible]
WE WERE.
I THINK HE'S HAD.
IF GOING FAIRLY RECENTLY ABOVE
OBVIOUSLY IT UP [inaudible]
LOOK INTO [inaudible]
ALL OF CENTRAL TEXAS DR.
FOST W. WENT OVER [inaudible]
BOB [inaudible]
VIA.
SO.
NO ONE CRIER [inaudible]
MORRELL.
BUT SHE COULDN'T TAKEOVER IN
MODERN.
TELLS HER SURE.
THOUSANDS [inaudible]
SEC.
VISUAL AT IT THIS IS THAT THIS
IS CLASSROOMS [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY [inaudible]
ENJOYED [inaudible]
PART OF THE EFFECT OF THE DRUG.
RIGHT NOW OKAY SO IF I'M CLOUT
WITHIN [inaudible]
TOTALLY [inaudible]
OKAY.
DRIVES HIGHER YEAH.
LONG AGO UP AT NIGHT YOU KNOW.
IT SEEMS A GOOD CD YEAH YEAH
THANK YOU TO VERIFY.
YOU AND CLIENTS THAT IDEA
[inaudible]
TAKING OVER
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH.
LIKE WORKING WITH. THREE DOUBLE
MURDER [inaudible]
YEAH.
HAVE ADDITIONAL MORE
RESPONSIBILITY --
PALE.
THE CABBIE LINGUISTIC OUT
FIGHTERS SAY I SHOULD THE THERE
ARE